Das war's für heute.
Wart mal ab.
Want to be with you forever.
Want to be with you ever.
Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Das ist auch aber so ein Channel, der in Deutschland niemals erfolgreich wäre. Nie.
Das ist einfach im deutschen Let's Player Reacting Land nicht angesagt.
Im deutschen Reacting Glücksspiel Land.
YouTube Deutschland ist eine Mischung aus irgendwelchen merkwürdigen Let's Plays von Leuten, die teilweise gar nicht spielen können.
Die, ich muss ja sagen, da ist es schon bedenklich, dass ich das jetzt sagen muss, aber die einzigen Leute auf YouTube in Deutschland, die halbwegs spielen können, sind die Fortnite Leute.
Der Rest ist Reaction und irgendwelche komischen Glücksspiel, Poker, Box Openings, pff, sonst
was Dinger.
Aber das war so einfach, das ist übelst nice.
Das war er absichtlich gemacht, oder?
Dass er die russische, die russische Nationalhymne einfach mal bei UK reingeschnitten hat.
Ich finde die lustig.
Ich hab bloß den einen.
Der fasst den das mal in die Steckerhose, ja.
Ich hab noch nie einen UK Stecker, doch ich hatte schon einen UK Stecker in der Hand von
meinem Headset, das kam aus UK und hat einen Adapter dabei gehabt, aber ich hab noch nie
einen UK Stecker in die Steckerhose gesteckt.
Also eins kann ich euch sagen, ist das eher ein Trollen Kanal, nee, gar nicht.
Das ist, ich sag ja, das ist ein Kanal, der wäre in Deutschland nicht erfolgreich.
Das ist lustig, einfach weil es gut gemacht ist und er hat teilweise mit die besten Erklärungen
so aus dem Elektronikbereich, die ich kenne.
Der Typ, der ist überhaupt nicht, jetzt musst du dir mal mehr Videos sagen, ich finde den
überhaupt nicht unsympathisch, der ist übelst nice.
Aber eins kann ich euch sagen, dieser komische Adapter wird das Video garantiert nicht überleben,
so wie ich den kenne.
Ah,
der Kram, der Kram wird das Video nicht überleben.
Das erste ist natürlich mal den Sicherungsschalter im Hotelzimmer suchen, natürlich, was sonst
mir fällt kein Hotelzimmer ein, wo ich jemals einen Sicherungsschalter drin gesehen hatte.
Die
Make any shorts one of the interesting things about these bulky british plugs is that unlike their north american counterparts that have
Metal completely exposed on the live prongs. They have half of it plastic
So if it is inserted halfway and makes contact to live wires only plastic is exposed
So it's safer. I mean, it's something to be tested
I bought this adapter here in uk with proper ground and fuse and everything and if you look here
I shorted between the two prongs with a thin piece of wire
Now when I plug it in if this makes contact while these metals are exposed
This thing will pop open and I'll know otherwise if I have to push it further in it will push this piece of wire back
And nothing will happen and I'll know it's safe
Okay, it's definitely shorted let's plug it in
Okay, hopefully nothing will happen and I'll know oh oh oh
I better clean it up before they see it
Well, I basically ran away the breaker for all the room outlets just popped and I can't reset it so hotel has to fix that for me
Erst mal kurz abhauen bis das Zeug wieder funktioniert
Wupp wupp es
Wir haben ein extra smoke emote, leute
Ich habe gerade einen
Global warming man use led
Und das hotel hat sich wahrscheinlich gedacht warum ist unsere sicherung rausgeflogen just a redundant switch and not a breaker
Und wenn du hier schaust
Der schluss muss ziemlich tief sein bevor es einen kontakt macht
Ich weiß nicht warum mein test fehlte oder warum ich es so gemacht habe während ich es so gemacht habe
Vielleicht war mein Kabel hier in die Socke geschlossen anstatt von weg zu fallen
Also, das ist immer noch sicherer für einen schluss
Auch das was ich nicht ausgedacht habe war das
Hey, es gibt kleine Türen auf diesem Outlet, also kannst du da nichts hinsetzen
Der Grundschluss muss zuerst rein gehen um diese Türen zu locken
Wir haben 240 volt ac 50 hertz hier im uk
Back in 120 volt ac canada my thin wire would pop first before any breaker root because any similar home all around the world draws around the same power
Like 100 watt lamp is 100 watts anywhere
So things are designed to draw. Ich triggere das immer wenn alle aus na anstatt watt watts sagen
Was hat das s da hinten dran zu suchen
The current on 240 volt ac compared to 120 volts that puts much less stress on the power lines here and the breakers are set to trip at half the current compared to 120 volt ac
Also, the surge current through my thin wire is double on 240 volt ac
That's why i tripped the breaker in any case the uk outlets have these doors on their big ass holes
So nobody can stick anything in there das sagt hier aber auch keiner du sagst ja auch nicht
Zwei keine ahnung
Kmhs ja moment das s das hat das s da steht ja auch für sekunde
Bei watts steht das s definitiv nicht für sekunde
Was pro sekunde ergibt überhaupt keinen sinn weil watt ist schon pro sekunde also schon in watt drinne ist das
Watt ist energie pro sekunde also ist energie pro sekunde pro sekunde übelst beknackt
Und außerdem nein nein nein nein nein nein nein das muss ich jetzt immer wichtig tun kilowattstunde ist kilowattmahlstunde nicht kilowattstunde durch sekunde
Das ergibt ja noch weniger sinn
Das ist dann irgendwie eine steigerung oder sowas so viel mehr brauchst du pro sekunde oder so
Ja das gibt es allerdings ist das mal mal kilowattmahlzeit nicht durchzeit
Kws wird es geben das sind dann kilowattstunden mal malmahlzeit nicht durchzeit
Kws wird es geben das sind dann kilowattstunden mal sekunde aber das wäre ganz schön viel
Kwhs ist eine energie menge im endeffekt
Ja chat ist wieder richtig big brain heute
Es haben zu wenig leute gesubbt der eq ist zu niedrig noch
Er steigt erst mit ein paar subs
Ja wenigstens aber ein elektroniker hier am start
Wobei watt auch also gibt es ja verschiedene verschiedene grundlagen joule pro sekunde bzw energie pro sekunde
Deswegen ist es noch beknackter zu sagen watt pro sekunde
Das ist dann energie pro sekunde wie das steigt oder sowas keine ahnung es gibt keinen sinn
Also meine lieblings Bullshit Einheit ist das das ist das hier
btu stunde oder btu pro stunde das ist meine lieblings Bullshit Einheit
Wisst ihr was das ist das wird das wird bei manchen usvs verwendet
Das ist british thermal unit pro stunde das heißt british thermal unit ist eine einheit
Wie viel energie es braucht das ist das ist so so best of Bullshit Einheiten
Wie viel energie es braucht ein ich glaube ein Pfund
Irgendwie ein Pfund Wasser um ein Grad fahren halt zu das ist übelster Bullshit
Dass sowas überhaupt noch heute verwendet wird überlegt euch mal dass es so definiert als wäre man die
Ein britisches Pfund Wasser um ein Grad fahrenheit zu erweiten warum verwendet man sowas 2019 noch
Was ist das alter was was ist mit dem was ist mit dem nicht richtig im kopf
Und jetzt gucken wir uns das nochmal an was wir eben drüber geredet haben was ich meine ist das hier
1 joule pro sekunde und bei elektronischem zeug ist es relativ simpel dann ist es volt mal amper
Wobei es nicht so einfach ist aber wie gesagt ich bin auch kein krasser elektrotechnikorps
Können wir einfach das video weiter schauen
Aber das ist wirklich eine kackeinheit das ist eine richtig
Auch für auch für kühlende geräte von rechenzentrum wird die ab wird die in abwärme abgegeben
Verluste in btu sowas beknackt ist in bei usv ist auch usv steht an btu pro stunde drauf
Und so
Da wir wir gucken wir müssen uns jetzt den sellout von ihm angucken
Echt jetzt haben wir unsere stecker aber nicht
Zu den steckern sind keine sicherungen drin oder oder nie gesehen
Das ist gar nicht so blöd
Ich finde es ja schon mal interessant dass er in seinem hotelzimmer erst mal alle lampen aufschrauben sich das anguckt
Ich habe einen sub übersehen den haben wir hier
Macht ihr das nicht auch immer wenn ihr irgendwo zu gast seid das erste was ihr sucht ist erst mal die sicherungskasten
Das sollte jeder so machen erst mal wenn man neu in irgendeinem haus erst mal die sicherungskasten suchen
Ich habe einen sub übersehen den haben wir hier
Ich habe einen Sub übersehen den haben wir hier
Das war's für heute.
Das war's für heute
Das war's für vandaag.
Das war's für heute.
Und jetzt die Abschaffung des Soli auf den Weg gebracht.
Wenn also mal wieder jemand in eurem Umfeld die große Meckerei über die Politik in Berlin anstimmt, schickt ihm doch einfach einen Link zu diesem Video.
Die GroKo liefert.
Soldat ist kein Job wie ihr.
Ich, ich sag mal so, zum Thema Koalitionsvertrag erinnert sich, erinnert sich noch jemand an, ähm, Artikel 13 und solche Dinge?
Und, und online, äh, und irgendwelche, wie heißt es jetzt, Uploadfilter, Uploadfilter, erinnert sich da noch jemand dran?
Zufällig, ich weiß, ist schon wieder ein halbes Jahr her, dass unter anderem da drinnen steht, dass man das nicht macht.
Egal, das ist wurscht.
Aber die Aussage hier ist auch geil, oder?
Passt mal, wo war das?
Jetzt die Abschaffung des Soli auf den Weg gebracht.
Wenn also mal wieder jemand in eurem Umfeld die große Meckerei über die Politik in Berlin anstimmt, schickt ihm doch einfach einen Link zu diesem Video.
Die GroKo liefert.
Äh, Moment.
Warte mal, wo kam das denn jetzt mit den Zweidritteln?
Ach hier.
Pass mal auf, Zweidrittel, Zweidrittel?
Teilweise oder vollständig, Zweidrittel, teilweise oder vollständig.
Das heißt im Endeffekt nichts anderes, auf ein Drittel scheißt man komplett.
Also ein Drittel juckt keine Sau, was sie in den Vertrag reingeschrieben haben.
Und Zweidrittel arbeiten sie gerade dran und ein paar wenige Punkte davon haben sie schon umgeschlossen.
Das sagt hier überhaupt null aus.
Wenn also mal wieder jemand in eurem Umfeld die große Meckerei über die Politik in Berlin anstimmt, schickt ihm doch einfach einen Link zu diesem Video.
Die GroKo liefert.
Oh Mann.
Soldat ist kein Job wie jeder andere und wir wollen das besonders würdigen.
Am 1. Januar 2020 geht's los.
Jetzt können sie es umsonst fahren können.
Jetzt haben uns die Grünen gefragt, warum man an den Verhandlungen dazu eigentlich nur die CSU beteiligt?
Ja, warum denn wohl?
Wann habt ihr jemals was für die Bundeswehr getan?
Genau, noch nie.
Ich hab verweigert.
Das reicht.
Hab ich genug für die Bundeswehr getan.
Aber wenn ihr eure Meinung jetzt geändert habt, bitte, ihr seid immer willkommen.
Oh yeah.
So, das war's für heute.
Ich sag vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen.
Like, kommentiert und teilt das Video.
Like, subscribe, share.
Das hat er schon mal raus, der Armin.
Das kann er.
Ganz liebe Grüße.
Gehen nach Brandenburg und Sachsen.
Denn am Sonntag nicht vergessen, Tatort schauen.
Servus.
Also ehrlich gesagt, ich muss sagen, es war weniger cringe als gedacht.
Kleidung hatte ich am Anfang schon, da hat sich jetzt bestätigt.
Ich mein, das ist viel Bullshit gelabert im Endeffekt.
Tatort schauen.
Ich mein, das ist viel Bullshit gelabert, aber es ist okay, ja.
Also es gibt deutlich schlechter, produziertere Sachen von Leuten, die halt hip sein wollen.
Wie kann man Comments lesen jetzt dazu?
Ah, jetzt hier.
Comments.
Okay, was schreiben wir?
Super tolles Format.
Gefällt mir sehr gut.
Sehr gut gemacht, super.
Kurz, knapp, prägnant.
Kann man dieses kack Facebook-Ding hier unten eigentlich ausblenden?
Gefällt mir.
Guter Ansatz.
Der Facebook pisst dich alle.
Sehr gut, bitte weiter.
Wir brauchen mehr davon.
Das ist eigentlich ja ganz cool.
Jetzt kommen so viel zu euch.
Wenn das eure Strategie für cooler weiblicher Junge ist, dann gute Nacht.
Naja.
Ich mein, cooler als jetzt auf jeden Fall.
Ich mein, weniger cool geht eigentlich gar nicht.
Ähm, jünger?
Naja gut, ich mein, ich hab zumindest einen hingestellt, der keine 60 plus ist.
Ist doch schon mal was.
Und es musste ich alles auf Teufel kommen, raus, weiblicher sein.
Ich mein, nur weil sie einen männlichen Moderator hingestellt haben,
weil sie einen haben, ist ja nicht automatisch gleich Bullshit.
Ich mein, das ganze Video war schon ein bisschen gewollt und nicht gekonnt.
Ja, aber es war nicht so cringe, wie ich mir das vorgestellt hab.
Na gut.
Ja, ich fänd's aber ehrlich gesagt cool, wenn andere Parteien auch sowas in der Richtung machen.
So quasi, wer gewinnt den Cringe-War?
Und dann sinnlos Greta und Grün bashing zu machen, ist doch sinnlos.
Ist doch ein Witz.
Na warum?
Die bashen sich auch alle gegenseitig.
Also wenn ich ein Video machen würde als Partei, dann würde ich meine Gegner auch bashen.
Warum soll ich meine Gegner nicht bashen?
Das ist ja gerade Sinn und Zweck der Videos.
Aber es geht ja nicht darum, irgendwie was zu machen, was den Leuten nützt.
Es geht ja darum gewählt zu werden.
Und das macht man am besten, leider, indem man seine Gegner basht.
Und nicht indem man was Gescheites macht.
Was schon an sich beknackt ist aber.
Gegner bashen.
Als würde die irgendwas klimamäßiges interessieren.
Das Einzige was sie interessiert ist, dass die Leute sie wählen.
Das ist denen doch vollkommen egal.
Und wenn man gewählt werden will, reicht es auch wenn man einfach so tut als ob.
Es müssen plus genug Leute glauben.
Kann man Fenster nicht resize.
Das geht mir echt auf den Sack.
In welcher Bitrate streamst du?
Ich glaube 4 MBit gerade.
Aber auf dem Desktop ist das ja kein Ding.
Da ist das ja alles gratis.
Wir kriegen keine gescheiten Videos empfohlen.
Da muss ich jetzt mal ein Video aus meiner Playlist raussuchen.
Und wir gucken uns wieder.
Ich guck gerne diese Videos vor die Leute.
Da haben wir uns jeden Sonntag mindestens einen angeguckt.
So diese Videos wo die Leute irgendwelche alten PCs restauren.
Ich guck das einfach unglaublich gern.
Also oller Mist.
Wieso hast du im Zoom einen 200% auf YouTube?
Damit ich...
Oh das klingt sogar nach einem interessanten Thema.
Oh Diablo was completely reverse engineered without source code.
Damit das Video hier im Fullscreen ist.
Dass das Video im Kino Mode im Fullscreen ist.
Dass ich nicht Fullscreen machen muss.
Deswegen...
Dann gucken wir uns das an.
Klingt sogar ganz interessant.
Von dem haben wir schon ein paar Sachen geguckt.
Der ist ganz gut.
Wie viele Mal in den letzten zehn Jahren, wenn wir über eine Port von Final Fantasy VIII oder Parasite EVE zu modernen Konsolen reden,
dass es nicht möglich war, wegen einer verlassenen Source zu sein.
Die Source-Kode ist eine grundlegende Kode, die von einem Programmer geschrieben wird,
die dann kompiliert werden kann und dann von einem Target-Computer oder Game-Konsol gedreht wird.
Die Hauptwache ist, dass sie einfach gelesen werden und von Menschen verstanden werden.
Als ich über.mu endlich Final Fantasy VIII wiederholte,
antwortete die Frage, wie man genau die Source-Kode verliert.
Und wie man die Source-Kode verliert, ist relativ einfach.
Um ein Spiel ohne Source-Kode zu rekonstruieren.
Es gibt viele Spekulationen um Final Fantasy VIII,
dass die Kode auf einen lang verpassten Backup-Tapen oder CD oder woanders war.
Aber die Chancen sind ziemlich schlau.
Es wurde well known, dass in den 90ern Square keine Form von Versionskontrolle usw. hatte.
Und wahrscheinlich hat man alte Hardware komplett mit den Kopien der Source-Kode geschützt.
Über Zeit wurde die Kode verpasst und vergessen.
Ich meine, die hatten ja damals...
Damals war es ja noch nicht so, dass du irgendwie ein Software, dass du irgendwie ein Git oder sowas hattest.
Also ganz früher, die Leute hatten quasi irgendwie einen Fileserver oder sowas
und haben da den Source-Kode drauf kopiert.
Und dann ist der Fileserver verreckt und das Source-Kode verpackt.
Warum sollte man auch, warum sollte man auch einen Backup machen, ne?
Das ist komplett overrated.
LB Pro, das habe ich mir angeguckt.
Das ist nicht so einfach. Du brauchst ja noch die ganzen Texturen und Sachen.
Die sind ja alle nicht dabei.
Das gibt's.
Haben sie noch irgendwelche Debug-Informationen drinne?
Nice game.
Ja, Diablo, ja, das habe ich schon mal gelesen.
Das soll erstmal rundenbasiert gewesen sein.
Alter, sah das erste Warcraft-Scheiße aus.
Waria war übelst underpowered.
Wizard war eindeutig die beste Klasse in Diablo 1.
Ja, Diablo 1 hat es geschafft, komplett random generierte Umgebung zu haben,
was Diablo 3 bei Release nicht geschafft hat.
Diablo 3 bei Release ist fast komplett statisch.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das so verkacken konnte.
Ja, ja, doch, da mach ich was zu. Da mach ich was zu noch.
Hat ich mir extra aufgeschrieben, ich weiß bloß noch nicht, wie ich das verpacken soll,
so dass es für die meisten Leute auch interessant ist.
Aber ich, ich kann es ja der Stelle vielleicht...
Wir können es an, wir können uns das, ähm...
Hast du mal einen Link zu deinem Comment?
Wir können, wir können uns das mal kurz im Stream angucken, dann kann ich dir was zu sagen, weil, ähm...
Ich war früher in einer recht ähnlichen Situation,
und diese, diese schulische Ausbildung, die du machst, bringt dir halt nichts von dem, was man da lernt.
Das ist komplett sinnlos.
Das einzige, was es dir bringen würde, ist Abi bzw. Fachabi,
falls du studieren willst.
Aber die Ausbildung an sich ist komplett für'n Arsch.
Also die bringt dir gar nichts, das interessiert keinen Menschen, dass du die gemacht hast.
Außerdem kannst du auch heutzutage, zumindest in Hessen,
gibt's die Möglichkeit, dass du sogar mit Realschulabschluss studieren kannst,
wenn du später studieren willst.
Vor allem, wenn du Berufserfahrung hast.
Also Abi ist gar nicht mehr unbedingt notwendig.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es in anderen Bundesländern ist.
In Hessen, in Hessen ist es so.
Ja, es gibt sogar in Hessen mittlerweile ein Testprogramm.
Hab ich gelesen bei der Uni Frankfurt.
Das war ein Testprogramm.
Da musst du noch nicht mal was gelernt haben.
Du kannst direkt mit einem Realschulabschluss sagen,
hier, ich will studieren.
Das Einzige, was du dann machen musst, ist,
quasi belegen, dass du hingehst
und dass du die Prüfungen schaffst zwischendurch.
Was hier irgendwie auch logisch ist.
So einfach sinnlose Leute da hinsetzen will man wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Also es gibt in Hessen ein Programm, da kannst du direkt,
also da kannst du ohne irgendwelche Voraussetzungen
mit Realschulabschluss studieren.
Wie gesagt, du musst bloß belegen, dass du hingehst
und dass du die Prüfungen packst.
Also die wollen halt nicht irgendwelche Leute da hinsetzen,
die einfach nur Däumchen drehen.
Also ich glaube, das ist das Problem.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es einen Playstation 1 Port von Diablo überhaupt gibt.
Wenn man sich die krispen SVGA-Visuel der PC-Version anschaut,
gibt es etwas Lackes.
V.a. wegen der Bedeutung des Playstation-Hardware selbst.
Climax hat ein guter Job mit dem, was sie hatten.
Es gibt sogar einen 2-Play-Lokal-Koop,
welcher eine tolle Option ist.
Zurück auf dem PC.
Diablo hatte damals Windows 95,
mit einem Maus, Keyboard und CD-ROM-Druck,
und zumindest einen Pentium-Prozessor,
der 60 Mhz war.
Es benötigte auch DirectX 3,
für seine Grafik-API.
Für die längste Zeit,
versuchte Diablo auf modernen PCs zu fahren,
ist fast unmöglich.
Es gab einige 3rd-Party-Patches und Hacks,
die man benutzen konnte,
mit einigen verschiedenen Niveaus von Erfolg.
Aber für Jahre war es schwierig,
das Spiel zu runnen,
unless man an einen alten Windows 95-Computer hatte.
Die meisten Leute hatten es nicht zu beobachten,
und das Spiel wurde nur in Bezug auf die Sequels verlassen.
Es war nicht bis jetzt,
als GOG Diablo 1 und 2
für die modernen Maschinen
vor diesem Jahr veröffentlicht hat.
Die GOG-Version veröffentlicht Routinen
in den veröffentlichten Grafiken und Sound-APIs,
um dir die Spiele auf deinem modernen PC zu spielen,
und dir die Hacks und Slashes
zu deinem Herzen.
Ich würde immer Diablo 2 vorziehen.
Diablo 2 war mit Abstand das beste Game in der Serie.
Das war überraschend.
Der Reinhardt,
der Reinhardt-Rollplayer,
der heißt doch auch so.
Das kannte jemand?
Der teilweise Overwatch streamt,
der macht auch solch Dragon-Streams.
Der hat mal einen Reinhardt-Rollplay-Stream gemacht.
Das war übelst lustig.
so gelabert hat, als wäre er Reinhardt.
Der hieß so, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es den noch gibt.
Man muss sich mal überlegen, jetzt mal ernsthaft.
2001 gab es den letzten Patch.
Das Spiel ist 1995 rausgekommen.
Das ist auch schon eine lange Zeit.
Ich meine, das war jetzt damals nicht so
unnormal, dass man Spiele eine Weile
supportet hat, aber Blizzard
ist bekannt dafür gewesen, Spiele wirklich
extrem lang zu supporten. Man darf nicht vergessen,
für Diablo 2, das kam glaube ich 1998 oder so
raus, oder 1999,
auf jeden Fall, ein bisschen
her schon, gab es sogar
letztens erst noch einen Patch.
Das richtige Weg, das Spiel voranzubringen, ist, das Spiel zu reverse-engineeren. Revers-Engineering kann lediglich
tausende über tausende Stunden erzielen,
aber im Fall von Diablo,
ein Lack der Aufmerksamkeit
hat dieses Spiel deutlich
einfacher zu brechen.
In Japan hatte Sony eine lange Reputation,
nicht die Doppelteckung von Sachen, die auf Retail-Kopiers
von Spielen übrig sind.
Back in 2013, die ganze
Sourcecode für Beatmania 5. Mix
was discovered on a Beatmania
best hits Playstation. Sony hatte schon ein paar Sachen,
wo einfach komische Dinger auf den
CDs noch drauf waren, oder in den Spielen.
And when Climax Studios was given the job
of porting Diablo to the Playstation 1,
naturally, Blizzard had sent
them the sourcecode as their starting point.
But somehow inexplicably
on the Japanese version of Diablo 1
contained a file on the disc
with the extension.sym.
Now if you're not... Das ist
...
..
Grafik. Dafür braucht man so ein Debug-File, so ein Symbol-File, dass man eben weiß, wie der Kram heißt.
Kommentar ist zu lang, wie verlinke ich den? Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung. Ich kann den Comment gleich raussuchen.
Du musst mal, sag mal nur noch mal, unter welchem Video das gewesen ist. War das unter dem, dem, dem, dem...
Das war nicht im Battlefield-Video, ne? Das war davor. Das war das dem, so gut oder schlecht, oder gut vs. schlechtes Modern Warfare oder so, ne?
Kann man es gleich angucken. Zu dem Comment kann ich gleich im Streben was sagen.
Deswegen gibt es den Release-Build. Deswegen kannst du normalerweise im Debug-Mode oder im Release-Mode kompilieren.
Und wenn du im Release-Mode kompilierst, dann hast du keine Debug-Symbols drinne.
Alternativ gibt es unter Linux das Kommando strip. Das hat nichts irgendwie mit sonst was zu tun, sondern damit kann man Debug-Symbols aus dem, aus dem Binary entfernen.
Aber hatten sie wahrscheinlich keinen Bock drauf.
Ja, das kommt noch dazu, BeatBot. Eigentlich ist die Release-Version, die du kompilierst, ohne Debug-Symbol auch schneller.
Gut, muss die ja auch haben. Ohne läuft das Spiel ja nicht.
Oh, huge Programming-Skills kommen jetzt.
Oh, übrigens Leute, Moment, ich muss mal kurz unterbrechen. Ich hatte eine richtig geile Idee für ein Stream und ein Video.
Zeig euch mal was. Ich wollte mir, ich wollte mir irgendeine kleine Programmier-Aufgabe ausdenken und dann wollte ich auf Fiverr, dann wollte ich auf Fiverr Programmierer suchen, die das für mich programmieren.
Mit Source-Code. Und dann gucken wir uns, gucken wir uns an im Stream oder im Video, was die Leute auf Fiverr programmiert haben.
Hire Overwatch-Code.
Du lässt ernsthaft Sachen auf Fiverr programmieren? Ja, was denn so zum Beispiel?
LP, PlayFair, für was? Ach, hier oben. Hey Max, ich fahre morgen meine Ausbildung als Fachinformatiker für Systemintegration an. Hältst du Tipps oder Sachen, die du damals anders gemacht hättest?
Eigentlich nicht. Kommt immer ein bisschen auf den Laden an. Eigentlich nicht. Das einzige, was du dir merken solltest ist, je nachdem, welchem Laden du landest, du machst die Ausbildung nicht, weil du schon alles kannst,
sondern weil du es lernen musst oder weil du es lernen willst. Wir haben einige Azubis schon gehabt, die auch der Meinung waren, so nach dem Motto, sie wissen alles, was in der Regel nicht stimmt.
Es ist vollkommen okay, wenn du in deiner Ausbildung von was keine Ahnung hast. Es sollte natürlich immer weniger werden mit der Zeit.
Okay, ja, das können wir echt mal. Wir brauchen plus. Wir brauchen nur, wir brauchen nur irgendwas, was man, so Programming Desktop Application.
Gucken wir mal. So, Desktop Application. So, dann müssen wir uns irgendeine kleine Aufgabe ausdenken. Was sind das für Preise? Gucken wir mal. Kann ich jetzt keine Raute machen?
Ich werde Programming machen. Track Stream. Huge. Stufe 1. Dankeschön. So, wir gucken jetzt mal kurz hier, was das so kostet.
Starting at 477. Und dann gucken wir das Video fertig und dann beantworte ich das Comment von, oh, ich hab's schon wieder vergessen, von Track Stream zu seiner Ausbildung.
Also hier zum Beispiel, I will do C sharp, C++, C and Java Programming. Also, oder wie die coolen Leute sagen, Java Programming.
So, was kostet's? Economy Package 477. Programs language select will consist of a single class or multiple short classes, including source code. Standard.
Moment, der will jetzt ernsthaft, bezahlt er nach Klassen? The fuck, was ist das? Was ist das? Okay, was könnte der zum Beispiel für uns programmieren?
Wir brauchen, Leute, da müssen wir uns echt mal Gedanken machen. Wir brauchen irgendeine kleine Aufgabe, einen Twitch-Bot oder sowas, oder einen Twitch, der soll einfach einen Pepega-Bot programmieren, was wir auch schon mal programmiert haben im Stream.
Also quasi eine ASP.NET Web Anwendung, die in einem Twitch-Channel schaut, wenn ich erwähnt werde und es dann darstellt. Die sollen einfach das Pepega-Bot nochmal neu programmieren.
Das ist total kurz und knackig, das machst du innerhalb, das machst du mit, haben wir ja gesehen im Stream, das machst du ja mit zwei, drei Codefiles, das ist ja nicht viel, das hat vielleicht 400, 500 Zeilen Code oder so, mit dem ganzen C sharp geblubbert drum herum.
Die sollen das Pepega-Bot programmieren. Also wer das Pepega-Bot nicht kennt, ich hab's hier irgendwie gerade kaputt gemacht. Ich zeig euch das mal kurz. Das ist nicht viel, das ist ein Programm, was im Prinzip aus ein bisschen HTML besteht.
Funktioniert's eigentlich mittlerweile? Geht das Pepega-Bot wieder? Warum nicht? Was hab ich da kaputt gemacht? Ja ich hab's kaputt gemacht, ich weiß nicht warum. Ich hab nichts dran geändert, aber es startet nicht mehr.
Das lassen wir die programmieren, das ist wirklich gut. Das ist auch wirklich simpel, das ist simpel, das kann fast jeder, deswegen ist das ein guter Auftrag für so einen Fiverr Typ.
Also gucken wir mal an, bei dem würde das 4,77 Euro kosten. Wir buchen Standard, weil du kannst das ohne Probleme in fünf Classes ohne Probleme machen.
Ich zeig euch mal, wie das Pepega-Bot source code-mäßig bei mir aussieht. Leider kann ich's nicht starten, weil ich's irgendwie zerstört hab. Ich weiß auch nicht, was ich gemacht hab, aber irgendwie hab ich's kaputt gemacht.
Rider was unable to detect Emma's build. Kann es sein, dass ich meine Rider-Settings irgendwie geschrottet habe? Not found. Warum?
Ah. Ahja. Save, vielleicht geht's jetzt. Load failed. Reload. Geht es jetzt? Ah. Ich hätte das vielleicht nicht updaten sollen.
Also ich zeig euch mal, was wir die beauftragen können zu programmieren. Das ist total simpel. Das ist im Prinzip mehr oder weniger fast schon alles.
Ein bisschen HTML und ein bisschen C-Sharp. Sollen wir mal starten das Ganze? In der Hoffnung es läuft jetzt. Okay. 5000. Also machen wir mal auf. Pepega-Bot. Da ist es. Genau. Das Programm macht nichts anderes, wie sich in den Twitch-Chat einzuloggen und alle Fragen, die Ad-Channel-Besitzer sind mitzuschneiden.
Das ist alles. Mehr macht das nicht. Und man hat einen Knopf zum löschen. Der eigentliche oben alles löschen sollte, aber es nicht macht. Das war's.
Also das ist wirklich nicht großartig kompliziert. So was sollen die programmieren? Guck, der schneidet mit, was der Chat grade. Was der Chat bastelt. Was man dazu braucht, ich sag ihm, ich hätte das gerne als ASP.NET Core-Anwendung. Was man dazu braucht ist, gut Startup zählt nicht, Startup ist default im Template.
Was man dazu braucht ist eigentlich nur eine HTML-Seite, die 118 Zeilen lang ist, inklusive CSS und JavaScript. Und was man dazu braucht ist eine Klasse, die sich in Twitch-Chat einloggt.
Und einen Mini-Controller, der das Ganze ausliefert. Also das sind, wie gesagt, ich hab gesagt 400 Code-Zeilen, das ist noch weniger. Das sind 40, das sind 40, das sind 20, 60, 100, 160.
160 Zeilen C-Sharp braucht man inklusive Boilerplate und allem. Und 120 Zeilen HTML. Also das ist nix im Endeffekt. Das machst du in zwei Stunden, wenn du keine Ahnung von hast.
Und das geben wir mal denen hier als Auftrag. Das probier ich echt mal aus. Die kriegen das als Auftrag und dann schauen wir mal, was für Software rauskommt. Ich glaub, das ist ganz interessant.
Ich mein, der Typ hat ja auch hier C-Sharp, hat er auch HTML. Na gut. Wir können ihn trotzdem beauftragen. Dann gucken wir mal, was rauskommt. Web-Programming.
I will create ASP.NET MVC-Web-Application. 238, das ist mir zu teuer. Gibt es bei euch noch einen Azubi zum Vergleich? Mir fällt gerade kein Anwendungs-Entwicklungs-Azubi ein bei uns, der das machen könnte.
Wieso willst du unbedingt was beauftragen, was du schon kannst? Na das, was mit dem vergleichen kann, was ich selbst gebastelt hab. Warum soll er das denn in ASP.NET machen?
Naja, weil das ein Web-Framework ist, von dem ich Ahnung hab. Ich kann schlecht Java, Swing beurteilen, was er da programmiert hat. Swing ist nicht so im Detail.
I will do Web-Apps with ASP.NET and SQL. Na dann zeig mal her, was kostet's? Basic development and bug fixing. I will create responsive application from scratch.
Okay, das gucken wir uns dann mal an. Also, wir schauen uns jetzt erstmal das Video fertig an zu Diablo und dann gucken wir uns das Comment von unter die Youtube-Video an. Vom Trackstream.
Oder haben wir jemand, der sich auch hier im Stream dran versuchen möchte?
Dann können wir das nämlich mit jemand hier aus dem Stream vergleichen und was die Leute bei Fiverr abliefern.
Der Eax möchte es mal am PP-Garboard. Nur in Node. Können wir machen, Node krieg ich auch. Kann ich mir auch angucken und lesen. Und halbwegs einschätzen. Wenn das Frontend mit Angular auch okay ist, kannst du das Frontend machen mit was du willst.
Nur das Backend hätte ich gerne in ASP.NET Core. Frontend kann man machen in was man will. Ein Frontend ist in Ordnet wirklich gerade die Ausgeburt der Schönheit hier irgendwo.
Frontend in Excel. Wenn ihr das in Excel machen wollt, wäre ich sogar auch dabei.
Was machen, habe ich mitgenommen. Die Idee war, dass ich das PP-Garboard, was ich mal programmiert habe, also diese 250 Code-Zeilen, der quasi dieser Twitch Chatlogger, den wollte ich nochmal beauftragen auf Fiverr programmieren zu lassen.
Und dann mal gucken, was da rauskommt. Dann habe ich bei der Gelegenheit gesagt, wir können es ja mal so machen, vielleicht möchte jemand im Stream sich auch da dran versuchen und das zu programmieren.
Wie gesagt, da brauchst du wahrscheinlich zwei Stunden oder so für, dann hast du was ganz Gutes zusammen. Und dann vergleichen wir mal, was die Leute hier im Stream fabrizieren, zum Vergleich was irgendwie einen 9,53 Euro Programmierer von Fiverr oder einen 4,77 Euro Programmierer von Fiverr verzapft.
Hat man das nicht so in 30 Minuten? Ja. Also ich würde mal so zwei Stunden ansetzen. Challenge accepted. Also was man machen soll, was man machen muss, ist im Prinzip ganz einfach.
Also ich zeige euch gar nicht, was man machen muss, sondern nur was am Ende rauskommen soll. Ich möchte den Webinterface haben, was Chatnachrichten mir anzeigt, die an mich gestellt wurden.
Live, ja. Also gerade laufend im Stream. Also wenn ich jetzt hier irgendwie eine Adwobe losschreibe, will ich, dass das Ding das mitloggt, sodass ich keine Fragen mehr übersehen kann.
Das ist das, was rauskommen soll. Das muss im Frontend nicht so aussehen, das ist die Funktionalität, die ich haben will.
Und ich hätte gerne das Backend in ASP.NET Core und das Frontend ist mir vollkommen egal. Ich meine das Frontend sollte im Browser laufen, aber mit welchem Framework ihr das macht,
ob ihr das mit from scratch, irgendwelche jQuery Geschichten oder direkt JavaScript im Browser, ist mir egal. Ja. Und am besten dann das Ganze auf GitHub, dass wir es uns angucken können.
Und nachher beauftrage ich auf Fiverr ein paar Leute, das auch sowas zu programmieren. I will create your website in ASP.NET MVC für 477.
Das glaube ich nicht. Für 477 würde ich als Programmierer nicht mal aufstehen und mich einloggen.
Was soll programmiert werden? Wir machen das anders. Ich schreibe mal einen Text zusammen, den ich auch den Fiverr Jungs schicke.
Und den gleichen Text lade ich auf Pastebin hoch und wir können das gleich schreiben. Wir gucken jetzt erstmal das Video fertig, dann beantworte ich die Frage von Trackstream unter YouTube
und dann schreiben wir einen Text zusammen für die Fiverr Leute, was programmiert werden soll. Der Zodiac abonniert zwei Monate. Dankeschön, nice.
Ihr sollt das gratis machen, ihr müsst ja nicht. Ihr könnt mitmachen, wenn ihr wollt. Ich habe es ja schon selbst programmiert, das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Das ist einfach nur just for fun. Aber vielleicht, ich wollte gerade sagen, vielleicht verkaufe ich es dann auch irgendwie nach Indien oder so.
Und ich gebe das irgendeinem indischen Microsoft Support Scammer.
Niki30, Twitch Prime, zwei Monate, huge. Nächsten Monat brauche ich neue, neue Sub-Batches.
Moment, der hat die App jetzt auf der Switch zum Laufen gekriegt. Hab ich gar nicht richtig aufgepasst.
Maxi7, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Also wenn ich das richtig sehe, der hat quasi den Playstation Diablo Source Code irgendwie umgewurstet, dass er auf der Switch läuft.
Das ist cool.
Die Final Fantasy VIII-Story war von Hardcoded teilweise.
Das schöne an den alten Games ist ja auch, dass sie noch irgendwie halbwegs übersichtlich sind. Reverse-Engineer mal sowas wie Crysis.
Der ist vorbei.
Sag ich mal, ja.
Niki30, hast du eigentlich eine neue Stelle gefunden? Nee. Ich habe ja gar nicht richtig gesucht. Ich bin ja eigentlich ganz zufriedener, wo ich jetzt gerade bin.
Aber ich gucke jetzt in letzter Zeit, weil ich kann jetzt mir was Neues suchen. Das ging ja die letzten Jahre über gar nicht.
Jetzt bin ich einfach mal ein bisschen gucken, was es so gibt. Ich will aber nicht unbedingt wechseln.
Welchen AP Endpoint hast du verwendet, um alle Messages im Chat zu bekommen?
Wenn ich jetzt zeige, wie ich es gemacht habe, ist es ja langweilig.
Max, warum bekomme ich, wenn ich hier im Chat bin, immer irgendwelche Scam-PMs? Deswegen habe ich PMs ausgeschaltet.
Oh, das war es für unsere Low-Level-Fans hier.
Das ist so eine richtig typische C++-Klasse. Einfach mal eine Klasse 653 Zeilen lang. Und das ist noch eine kurze C++-Klasse.
Wenn du mal manche Qt-Klassen anguckst, dann sind die irgendwie 8000 Zeilen lang oder so.
Warum hättest du den Job nicht wechseln können? Können hätte ich schon. Aber ich habe mich dafür entschieden, das Programm, was die zur betrieblichen Altersvorsorge anbieten, abzuschließen.
Und es gibt so eine komische Regelung, dass wenn du das abschließt, da bezahlst du ja unter Arbeitgeber Teile ein.
Und die Teile, die der Arbeitgeber einbezahlt hat, können verfallen, wenn du nicht so und so lange dabei bleibst.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal das Comment zur Fach-Informatik-Ausbildung an von Nixer. Irgendwas mit Nixer war es im Namen.
Kann ich jetzt nämlich was zu sagen.
Wirst du die Modern Warfare-Kampagne spielen? Ja, klar.
Ja, da ist er. Also, um dieses Comment geht es. Kann ich mir noch dran erinnern. Wollte ich nämlich eh schon was zu sagen, habe ich ja auch hier schon angekündigt.
Wollte ich eigentlich ein Video machen. Also er schreibt hier, Hi Max, kannst du vielleicht noch mal was zur Ausbildung zum Studium in der Informatik machen?
Wie gesagt, ich habe ja nicht studiert. Ich kenne zwar jede Menge Leute, die studiert haben, aber ich glaube, ich habe nicht studiert.
Aktuell sieht die Lage bei mir so aus, dass ich auf einem informationstechnischen Berufskolleg eine Schulausbildung mit Abitur mache und alles anzweifle.
Denn sowohl Technische Informatik als auch Programmiertechnik und Elektrotechnik, aber auch Englisch liegt mir einfach anders als beispielsweise Französisch und Mathe.
Dass die Französisch nicht liegt, kann ich verstehen.
Ähm, morgen geht das ganze Spaß in die zweite Runde, die sogenannte Q1 und ich habe seit sechs Wochen Bauchschmerzen.
Kenne ich auch, hatte ich früher auch. Ich habe ja auch ein paar Sachen gemacht, wo ich keinen Bock drauf hatte.
Das sagt richtig. Wenn du Sommerferien hast und dann quasi schon ab der Hälfte der Sommerferien denkst, oh fuck, demnächst muss ich wieder hin.
Das ist scheiße. Das hat auch keine Zukunft. Und ich habe seit sechs Wochen Bauchschmerzen, wenn ich an morgen denke.
Deshalb ist mir eigentlich klar, dass ich etwas ändern muss.
Da mir Informatik im Gegensatz zu Mathe und Co. schon immer Spaß gemacht hat und man sagen muss, da wird jetzt der studierte Informatiker Sachen, dass man das gar nicht wirklich trennen kann.
Aber ich weiß, was du meinst. Du meinst Rumbasteln an Hardwaren, du meinst Netzwerkgeschichten, du meinst irgendwelche Software Sachen.
Du meinst jetzt nicht die Hardcore Theorie, was Programmieren und Mathe angeht.
Ich habe mit vier meinen ersten Rechner zusammengebaut und mit fünf mein erstes kleines C-Programm geschrieben.
Also ganz ehrlich gesagt, wenn du gerne programmierst, bist du wahrscheinlich in Mathe nicht schlecht. Du hast plus diese komische Mathe-Geschichte aus der Schule im Kopf.
Natürlich beides mithilfe Erwachsener. Denke ich seit fast einem Jahr drüber nach, ob eine Ausbildung nicht doch besser gewesen wäre.
Mir ist klar, dass ich da auch Mathe brauche, aber garantiert muss ich da nichts von Kurvendiskussionen und Konsorten verstehen. Nein, brauchst du nicht.
Also während der Ausbildung Fachinformatiker brauchst du kein Mathe. Man braucht fast schon zu wenig Mathe.
Die Fachinformatiker-Ausbildung ist fast mathefrei. Man hat noch nicht mal in der Berufsschule Mathe. Man hat fast schon zu wenig.
Aber zurück zum Punkt zu kommen, wäre ganz nice, wenn du zu folgenden Sachen was sagen könntest.
Da finde ich, dass die meisten Online-Quellen das nicht wirklich hinreichen machen.
Wie viel hat die Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker in Mathe zu tun? Gar nichts.
Gar nichts.
Null.
Noch nicht mal in Programmieren. Das, was man in Programmieren in der Berufsschule macht, ist der komplette Witz.
Man hat im ersten halben Jahr ein bisschen Elektrotechnik. Da musst du multiplizieren und addieren.
Das war es fast schon. Mal irgendwie Potenz oder so. Aber nicht wirklich.
Was lässt sich Gehaltstechnik machen und wie wirken sich Qualifikationen auf das Gehalt aus?
Pauschal kann man sagen, wenn du studiert hast, verdienst du mehr. Wir sind in Deutschland.
Allerdings kann man das auch wirklich nur so pauschal sagen und im Einzelfall muss das nicht so sein.
Wir haben bei uns beispielsweise Leute, die haben studiert. Die arbeiten im 24-7-Support.
Und wir haben die übelsten Noobs, was Ausbildung angeht, die im Security-Team arbeiten.
Die sind keine Noobs, sondern haben nichts in der Richtung gelernt. Das hat vor allem nach ein paar Jahren Berufserfahrung nicht so entscheidend was zu sagen.
Aber man kann natürlich sagen, in der Regel verdienst du mehr Geld, wenn du was studiert hast.
Wie sieht es mit der Stabilität des Arbeitsplatzes aus?
Ich höre öfters das Informatiker auf ihre Arbeitgeber wechseln. Das kommt drauf an.
Wenn du selbstständiger bist, wenn du wie gesagt so schön Freelancer bist, was natürlich aber auch nur mit ein bisschen Erfahrung geht und vielleicht auch ein bisschen Kontakten.
Wobei heute nicht. Heute meldest du dich auf Xing an und trägst ein. Keine Ahnung, Eventual Basics.
Ich kenne mich mit Linux aus, kann ein bisschen Python programmieren.
Schon hast du die übelsten Typen am Start so nach dem Motto hier, wir wollen dich verschachern an irgendeinem Laden.
Also aktuell suchen sie händeringend überall Leute. Zumindest Frankfurt und Umgebung.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es im restlichen Teil von Deutschland nicht ganz so extrem sein wird, aber auch so.
Aber das ist nicht unbedingt der Fall. Ich habe meine Ausbildung gemacht.
Ich habe danach bei einem Hosting Anbieter gearbeitet und jetzt arbeite ich die restliche Zeit dort, wo ich jetzt immer noch bin.
Also ich habe, wenn du so willst, einmal gewechselt. Wenn man die Übergang Ausbildung mal weglässt.
Meinte mit Qualifikation so was wie... Ach du meinst so Zertifikate.
Das kommt drauf an. Das kommt ein bisschen drauf an.
Also Zertifikate an sich. Es gibt noch genug Läden, die irgendwie da drauf stehen.
Was für eine Art Hosting Anbieter war es denn? Genauso wie man sich das vorstellt.
Racks mit Servern drin, wo Zeug drauf gelaufen ist.
Es kommt ein bisschen drauf an mit Zertifikaten.
Also wenn das Zertifikate sind, die nicht 0815 sind, dann kann das schon was bringen.
Also wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel netzwerktechnisch was machen willst und du hast jetzt was höheres als CCNA, ist das sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
CCNA kannst du vergessen. Sogar ich habe eine CCNA.
Das machst du auf halbe Arschbacke und ich habe es nie verlängert.
Und ich bin nur wirklich jetzt nicht der oberkrasse Netzwerk Dude.
Aber die eine oder andere Zertifizierung kann mit Sicherheit was bringen, wenn es ein Laden ist, das darauf steht.
Es gucken aber immer mehr Betriebe drauf, letztendlich was man kann.
Also ich mache die ganze Zeit Zertifikate, das ist auch ein bisschen overrated.
Wie wird man als ausgebildeter Informatiker von Studierten behandelt?
Auf jeden Fall allen anderen auch.
Ich meine, du magst vielleicht den einen oder anderen haben, der sich geil findet.
Aber wie gesagt, das macht im Endeffekt danach keinen großen Unterschied.
Wie gesagt, wir haben Leute, die haben Informatik studiert.
Und jetzt nicht irgendwie Wirtschaftsinformatik oder so.
Wir haben Wirtschaftsinformatik, die haben Informatik studiert.
Die arbeiten bei uns quasi für ein Apple und ein i im 24-7-Support.
Und andere, die nicht studiert haben, haben richtig gut bezahlte, leitende Stellen.
Da würde ich mir eigentlich keine Gedanken drüber machen.
Bringt ein Cisco-Lehrgang wohl viel mit im dritten Jahr?
Es ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt, mal so ein Cisco-Lehrgang gemacht zu haben,
als man so ein bisschen weiß, wie man Cisco-Geräte konfiguriert.
Das ist nicht verkehrt.
Musik zu laut? Passt, denke ich, oder?
Habe von Bekannten und Verwandten gehört, dass die Akademiker oftmals dazu zendieren,
die Nase ganz weit nach oben zu stecken?
Nee.
Also habe ich jetzt nicht die Erfahrung gemacht.
Es gibt Leute, die sind generell so unabhängig davon, ob sie studiert haben oder nicht.
Es gibt Leute, die finden sich übertrieben geil.
Das sind allerdings meistens die, die nicht wirklich geil sind.
Du hast mal die eine oder andere Ausnahme, Leute, die sich geil finden und auch wirklich was können.
Aber das ist die Ausnahme.
Und Schleimer gibt es überall.
Ich würde sogar eher dazu sagen, dass Leute, die studiert haben und wissenschaftlich arbeiten können,
eher dazu tendieren, es mit Autoritäten nicht so ernst zu nehmen.
Aber bei den Vorgesetzten nicht zu schleimen.
Also, um den würde ich mir eigentlich wenig Gedanken machen.
Wie sind die Arbeitsbedingungen in den Unternehmen im Vergleich zu anderen Branchen?
Naja, wie gesagt, ich bin jetzt nicht bei 50 verschiedenen Läden gewesen oder so.
Allerdings kann man sagen, die Arbeit hat schon seine Vorteile.
Du bist nicht draußen in der Sonne und musst irgendwelche Sachen schippen.
Du hast in der Regel, je nach der Ausnahme, du arbeitest im Support,
relativ wenig mit unterschiedlichen Leuten zu tun.
Relativ wenig mit Endkunden zu tun, was ich eindeutig bevorzuge.
Auf Endkunden habe ich überhaupt keinen Nerv.
Auch auf viele unterschiedliche Leute habe ich keinen Nerv.
Aber ich habe schon oft gesagt, ich mag generell Leute nicht.
Aber deswegen sucht man sicher auch so eine Arbeit.
Also, ich würde sagen, die Arbeitsbedingungen sind eigentlich ganz gut.
Man muss immer gucken.
Das ist halt sehr davon abhängig, wo man landet.
Also, wenn du zum Beispiel bei irgendeinem Spieleentwickler landest
und ausgebeutet wirst, ist das was anderes,
wie wenn du beispielsweise bei irgendeiner Bank landest,
wo du für jede Änderung drei Wochen brauchst und die restliche Zeit Däumchen drehst.
Kommt auf den Betrieb an.
Aber letztendlich liegt es da auch ein bisschen mit an einem selber.
Man muss nicht jeden Scheiß mitmachen.
Also aktuell ist es so, wenn man was kann, was prinzipiell eh das Wichtigste ist.
Man muss was können.
Man muss sich nicht einfach nur in Windows einloggen können
und da drei Dinge AD anklicken oder so.
Ja, euch mag ich schon, weil ihr seid ja...
Aber auch nicht alle.
Ja, wie gesagt, man muss in der heutigen Zeit, hat man da auch ein bisschen die Auswahl,
wo man wirklich irgendwo landet, wo es extrem beschissen ist.
Man muss nicht jeden Mist mitmachen.
Also zum Beispiel einer der Gründe, warum ich damals gewechselt bin
von diesem Hosting-Anbieter, wo ich gewesen bin.
YukiTerror97, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Zum Name stelle ich mir irgendwie vor, anstatt Nice, so passt besser der hier.
Eine der Gründe, warum ich damals gewechselt bin von diesem Hosting-Anbieter,
zu da, wo ich jetzt bin, waren tatsächlich so ein paar Sachen,
die sie sich überlegt haben, die ich ziemlich beknackt fand.
Zum Beispiel haben sie sich überlegt, sie machen einen Ausbildungsprogramm,
also einen Fortbildungsprogramm, was die Firma bezahlt.
So weit so gut, sag ich ja nichts dagegen.
Allerdings haben sie dann gesagt, dieses Fortbildungsprogramm,
darfst du bloß samstags besuchen.
Da habe ich schon gesagt, Moment Leute, ich soll samstags auf die Fortbildung gehen,
quasi unbezahlt, ohne alles, dass ich da eine Fortbildung mache,
wo ihr dann im Endeffekt auch was von habt.
Also ich hätte dann quasi 5 Tage die Woche gearbeitet
und dann samstags quasi noch irgendwelche Fortbildungen gemacht.
Und dazu kam, dass sich einfach irgendwelche Fortbildungen waren,
es waren schwere Dinge, wo man auch lernen musste dafür.
Da war dann sowas wie Cisco Internet Engineer,
also wirklich Hammer-Artcore-Dinger dabei.
Oder auch irgendwelche Red Hat Geschichten, die wirklich nicht ohne waren.
Da musst du nicht nur mal kurz hingehen auf die Fortbildung,
sondern du musst da wirklich lernen für.
Und das ist so eine Sache, das machst du auch nicht in 3 Wochen mal.
Und dann haben sie sich überlegt, ja gut, das gibt es nur samstags die Fortbildung.
Du musst dich dazu verpflichten, dass du die Ausbildung bestehst,
was knackt ist, wie willst du dich dazu verpflichten?
Und du musst dich verpflichten, in einem halben Jahr so und so viel Fortbildung zu machen,
in einem Ausmaß, in Kombination mit samstags nur die Fortbildung
und unter einer Woche nicht lernen können, dass es komplett hirnrissig war.
Und da haben wir damals gefragt, wie ist es denn samstags,
ich will ja noch was anderes machen,
aber dann haben sie sich dazu dann durchgerungen zu sagen,
hey, ihr könnt natürlich die Fortbildung auch während der Arbeitszeit machen,
allerdings bekommt ihr dann die Arbeitszeit nicht gut geschrieben.
So nach dem Motto, ich mach dann Minus auf meinem Arbeitszeitkonto
und müsste nacharbeiten, weil ich einfach nicht eine Ausbildung für die Firma gemacht hab.
Und das war der Punkt, wo ich mir gesagt hab, leckt mich am Arsch.
Leckt mich komplett am Arsch, ihr könnt mich mal, ich geh woanders hin.
Deswegen mein ich, man muss nicht jeden Mist mitmachen, vor allem in der heutigen Zeit.
Captain Siegheit, zwei Monate, Hitsprime, dankeschön, nice.
Ich mein, ich arbeite doch nicht kostenlos.
Hast du da einen Flott eine neue Stelle gefunden?
Ich hatte direkt das, wo ich jetzt bin.
Am nächsten Tag, ist aber auch glücklich gelaufen.
Also ich hatte keine Downtime.
Dort Ende des Monats aufgehört und Anfang des Monats beim jetzigen angefangen.
Man muss aber dazu sagen, aber als du gekündigt hast, wusstest du das nicht.
Doch, doch, doch, das wusste ich zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Weil, das ist bei mir relativ glücklich gelaufen.
Wie gesagt, das war ein Hosting-Anbieter und der Hosting-Anbieter hat unter anderem
Teile des Hostings gemacht für den Laden, wo ich jetzt arbeite.
Wo arbeitest du denn da?
Finanzsektor in Frankfurt, auf einer Bank.
Der Hosting-Anbieter hat teilweise das Hosting gemacht für die Firma, wo ich jetzt bin.
Ich kannte die Leute da schon.
Deswegen ging das relativ gut.
Das einzige Problem war, dass in meinem Vertrag sowas drinne stand, wie
man darf der Firma keine Konkurrenz machen und so weiter.
Das war ein bisschen unbekannte Situation.
Das wird ja überhaupt nicht gehen.
Das fand ich richtig geil.
Da hat der neue Arbeitgeber dann einfach gesagt, ja verklagt uns doch.
Natürlich hat sie keiner verklagt.
Es gibt doch einen Abonnenten, der weiß.
Es gibt sogar zwei.
Ja, aber das ist schon zehn Jahre her oder gar nicht ganz.
Ist auf jeden Fall schon eine Weile her.
Okay, also weiter im Text.
Wie sind die Arbeitsbedingungen in den Unternehmen im Vergleich?
Das hatten wir gerade schon.
Was würdest du empfehlen?
Ich bin zwar erst 18, aber trotzdem denke ich, dass es kein Zustand ist,
dass ich an fast jedem Tag mit Bauchschmerzen...
Nein, das ist kein Zustand.
Das ist auch wirklich belastend.
Es gibt Leute, die sagen Alter, stell dich nicht so an, aber das ist
wirklich belastend.
Das kann ich nachvollziehen.
Das ist kein Zustand.
Das sorgt eher dafür, dass du irgendwelche Komplexe kriegst im Kopf, wenn du jeden
Tag mit Bauchschmerzen auf dich hingehen musst und mich in die Schule zwingen,
weil ich keinen Bock mehr auf Großteil der Fächer habe.
Fast jeden Tag, meistens weiter gebündelt, programmiere ich Elektrotechnik.
Ach gut.
Programmieren ist ja nice.
Programmieren scheint dir doch auch zu liegen, wenn du schon mit vier dein erstes
C-Programm programmiert hast.
Wie wichtig sind eigentlich Hochschulnoten, wenn man sich nach dem Studium
irgendwo als Anwältin sagt, wie?
Schulnoten juckt kein Mensch.
Auf der anderen Seite sind meine Eltern, meine Mutter im Besonderen nicht
zu begeistern.
Meine auch nicht.
Von der Idee, die Schule abzubrechen und eine Ausbildung anzufangen, da sie denkt,
dass studierte Informatiker bessere Bezahlungen zu besseren Arbeitszeiten,
zu besseren Arbeit...
Das stimmt.
So...
Im Durchschnitt mag das so sein, aber im Einzelfall...
Ich weiß immer noch nicht, ob das im Durchschnitt überhaupt so ist.
Ja, es ist bestimmt statistisch so, dass du in Deutschland, wenn du studiert hast,
immer mehr Geld verdienst als einer, also statistisch gesehen im Durchschnitt,
immer mehr Geld verdienst als einer, der nicht studiert hat.
Aber vor allem in dem Umfeld kommst, und das finde ich gut, hauptsächlich drauf an,
was du kannst.
Also wenn du dich in Bereichen auskennst, die gefragt sind, Bereiche, die vielleicht
auch nicht so viele Leute können, dann ist das scheißegal, ob du studiert hast
oder nicht.
Zum Beispiel aktuell, was voll angesagt ist, wenn du dich mit irgendwelchen Cloud-Geschichten
und Kubernetes und sowas auskennst.
Das ist zurzeit voll der Hype, da stehen sie alle drauf.
Und unabhängig davon, ob sie es brauchen oder nicht, aber viele Firmen denken,
dass sie das brauchen.
Das heißt, wenn du dich damit auskennst, und du musst dich damit auch nicht übertrieben
gut auskennen.
Das reicht schon, wenn du dich ein bisschen auskennst, weil damit kennst du dich besser
aus, als die meisten anderen da.
Und da gehen die ab, die wollen dich unbedingt haben.
Egal, es ist scheiß drauf, ob du studiert hast oder nicht.
Und sie sagt, dass ich das erstmal durchziehen soll.
Danke erstmal für das Lesen.
Gerne.
Also ich denke, du solltest dich mal danach umgucken.
Also diese Ausbildung hier an der Schule, das ist, wie nennt sich das, staatlich geprüfter
informationstechnischer Assistent oder sowas, glaube ich.
Das ist der übelste Bullshit.
Das braucht kein Mensch.
Das will kein Mensch haben.
Und das interessiert auch keinem, wenn er dich einstellt, dass du das hast.
Ich weiß, wir haben ein paar Leute im Chat, die auch dafür zuständig sind, zu gucken,
so nach neuen Leuten und sowas.
Könnt ihr mal in den Chat schreiben, ob euch das in irgendeiner Form interessiert.
So, ja, ich hab mich gemutet.
Wo war ich denn stehen geblieben?
Ja, also ob es euch in irgendeiner Form interessiert.
Also eigentlich bringt das gar nichts.
Das einzige, was das bringen würde, ist, wie gesagt, dass du vielleicht danach studieren
könntest.
Allerdings, ich kann das nachvollziehen.
Ich hätte wirklich keinen Bock mehr, das jetzt noch zwei Jahre zu geben.
Das dauert ja dreieinhalb Jahre.
Und ich denke auch nicht, dass Studieren wirklich, das ist zumindest zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
für dich, weil wenn du Informatik studierst, ein bisschen Hang zur Matte solltest du haben.
Aber jetzt kann ich dir sagen, manche Sachen kommen mit der Zeit.
Ich fand in der Schule Mathe übelst beschissen und auch danach.
Mittlerweile gucke ich mir auf YouTube Mathe-Vorlesungen an und gucke mir irgendwelche Mathe-Probleme
an und lese dazu Sachen und finde das zumindest in Teilen zau-mäßig interessant.
Manches kommt auch ein bisschen mit der Erfahrung, ein bisschen mit dem Alter.
Und vor allem, wenn man gerne programmiert.
Also ich sag mal so, alle, die gerne programmieren, und ich meine damit jetzt nicht CSS, HTML
in der Webseite machen, alle, die Spaß daran haben, was zu programmieren, was ein bisschen
Logik erfordert, sind in der Regel auch nicht ganz scheiße, was Mathe angeht.
Weil ihr müsst euch mal überlegen, wer hat Programmiersprachen erfunden?
Die ersten Programmiersprachen haben irgendwelche Hardcore-Mathematiker erfunden.
Also ich würde dir empfehlen, guck einfach mal, was es für eine Ausbildung gibt.
Es gibt mittlerweile viele Betriebe, die Leute suchen.
Und es bringt ja nichts, wenn du jetzt sagst, ich würde jetzt nicht instant die Schule abbrechen
ohne einen Ausbildungsplatz.
Ich würde aber vielleicht mal gucken, was man so findet.
Und dann, wenn ich was gefunden hätte, würde ich das sofort machen.
Weil diese schulische Ausbildung, wie gesagt, denke ich, bringt dir nichts.
Also das, den Titel, den du dann bekommst, wenn du diese Ausbildung geschafft hast, bringt
dir nichts.
Und das ist noch nicht mal das Papierwert, auf dem es steht.
Das Einzige wäre halt, dass du studieren kannst direkt danach.
Was aber wahrscheinlich, wenn du absolut kein Mathe-Fan bist, nicht das für dich ist.
Ich würde einfach nach einem Ausbildungsplatz suchen und eine Ausbildung anfangen.
Außerdem verdient es dann ordentlich Kohle, von Anfang an.
Dafür gibt es ja gar nichts.
Es gab noch eine Frage im Chat.
Wie wichtig sind all...
Einen Moment, hatten wir schon.
Hochschulnoten.
Es juckt keinen.
Stimmt es, dass es nur auf die Coding-Skills ankommt?
Naja, nicht nur.
Also natürlich muss man als Programmierer gut programmieren können.
Man braucht allerdings auch breite Kenntnisse, sage ich mal, in den Technologien, die eingesetzt
werden.
Nur weil ich gut programmieren kann, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass ich mit dem Umfeld
herum klarkomme.
Und was auch heutzutage als Programmierer und auch als, was mir auch immer ein bisschen
schwer fällt, muss ich sagen, als Programmierer, als auch als, egal welche Position, es ist
in der heutigen Zeit nicht verkehrt, wenn man mit Leuten halbwegs auskommt.
So will ich mal so ausdrücken, ja.
Wie gesagt, ich mag auch keine Leute.
Aber so komplett alleine in der Kammer sitzen und was vor sich hinhexen ist heute halt nicht
mehr.
Wobei ich auch deutlich weniger Probleme habe, mit Leuten auszukommen, die sich technisch
auskennen, als mit Leuten, die sich nicht auskennen.
Was machst du denn bei der Bank?
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Beruf.
Da haben wir eine Kommando-Firmen.
Ach du gehst gerne hin, wenn du Programmiertechnik im Kurs.
Ja, das passt doch.
Ich kopiere immer Buchstaben, wenn ich mich konzentrieren muss, wisst ihr doch.
Ist der Typ hier im Chat oder lest du das noch hoch?
Ich lade das nicht hoch.
Der ist im Chat, das ist er.
Trackstream ist das.
Äh, Dönerbruder.
Kommt drauf an.
Ich meine, du musst ja wissen, wo es dir mehr danach ist.
Man kann nicht pauschal Raten studieren oder Ausbildung machen.
Das muss man selber wissen, wo es einem mehr danach ist.
Pauschal kann man das schlecht beantworten.
Plutor29, Pock, Subscriber.
Ich komme mit dem Chat gerade nicht hinterher.
Okay, also Trackstream, ich hoffe dir hat das geholfen.
Was hältst du von Wirtschaftsinformatik?
Du kannst mich mit jeglichen BWL-Zeugs jagen.
Ich habe mal überlegt, mir ein wenig Programmieren beizubringen.
Ich weiß leider nur nicht, wo ich anfangen soll.
Überleg dir einfach, was du machen willst.
Was dir auf den Keks geht und was du gerne besser machen würdest.
Wenn du sagst, ich hätte gerne einen schöneren Win-aus-Taschen-Rechner,
dann willst du auf jeden Fall Desktop-Anwendung programmieren.
Oder willst du sagen, ich würde gerne eine Webseite machen.
Dann solltest du dir mal überlegen, ob du nicht JavaScript, CSS, HTML anfängst.
Und dann einfach mal schauen, was es für kostenlose Bücher gibt.
Oder vielleicht auch ein Buch kaufen.
Ich bin immer auch der Meinung, zum Einstieg und auch zum Vertiefen sind Bücher,
ordentlich geschriebene Bücher, besser als Online-Kurse oder YouTube-Videos.
Man kann sich natürlich Online-Kurse und YouTube-Videos dann angucken.
Aber wichtig ist, einfach ein bisschen programmieren.
Weil wenn du selbst programmierst, lernst du einfach das meiste.
Weil dir auffällt, in dem Moment, wo es nicht funktioniert,
dass du irgendwas brauchst, wovor du noch keine Ahnung hast.
Ja, Nicky, da hast du recht.
Wenn halt Menschen die Menschen nicht mögen untereinander sind, passt alles.
Ja, das stimmt so.
Waren wir heute noch?
Eigentlich wollte ich noch ein paar Videos gucken.
Und dann müssen wir noch Fiverr, müssen wir uns noch einen Fiverr-Text ausdenken,
den ich an die Fiverr-Leute schreiben kann.
Ja, das stimmt.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Wirtschaftsinformatik und Informatik?
Das eine hat halt BWL-Krempel mit dabei.
Und viel weniger Informatik.
Du kannst die gerne auf dem Discord veröffentlichen, wenn du willst, ja.
Aber ich finde, zum Einsteigen ins Programm, zum Einsteigen ins Programm ist am besten,
man hat irgendwas vor Augen, was man gerne machen möchte.
Was willst du über Fiverr machen lassen?
Ja, da schreiben wir gleich einen Text zu.
Ich will über Fiverr was programmieren lassen, was wir on stream auch schon mal programmiert haben.
Und dann mal schauen, was die 4,50 Euro-Programmierer von Fiverr so programmieren.
Gut, so, ich hab mit dem Chat wieder aufgeholt.
Es hat jetzt ein bisschen gedauert.
Erst mal alles durchscrollen.
Ja, das haben wir unsere gute Tat für heute schon getan.
Aber schön, dass du so ein ausführliches Comment geschrieben hast.
Was man daran auch erkennt, ist, dass du nicht einfach nur keinen Bock hast, den Scheiß zu machen,
oder dass du nicht generell einfach nur keinen Bock hast, irgendwas zu machen,
sondern dass du dir wirklich Gedanken machst.
Und deswegen muss ich halt echt sagen, das ist kein Zustand,
wenn du mit Bauchschmerzen morgens aufstehst, wenn du dahin musst.
Das ist für'n Arsch.
Und um die anderen Sachen musst du dir, wie gesagt, eigentlich kaum Gedanken machen.
So, ähm, ja, jetzt müssen wir.
Was schreib ich den Fiverr Leuten denn?
Gefällt dir die Skyline von Frankfurt?
Ja, Skyline von Frankfurt.
So Leute, irgendwie ist es gerade danach.
Mit scheiß Twitter-Qualität.
Ja, das ist die Skyline von Frankfurt.
Sieht doch ganz nett aus morgens, wenn's dunkel ist, oder?
Warum ist die Twitter-Qualität so scheiße, die ich hochgeladen hab?
Die Qualität müsste viel besser sein, das 1008-Spiel-Video.
Also ich finde, nachts sieht Frankfurt wirklich,
gut, das ist jetzt morgen grauen, sieht es wirklich ganz nett aus,
wenn man hier über die Brücke nach Frankfurt reinläuft.
Oder? Findet ihr nicht auch? Hat was.
Ich mein, ich hätte das Handy mal ein bisschen höher halten müssen,
dass man die Hochhäuser besser sieht, weil die gehen noch ein ganzes Stückchen weiter hoch.
Ich hatte auch ein schönes Bild nach Frankfurt nachts.
Frankfurt, Kaiserstraße.
Arbeitet ihr jetzt beim neuen Arbeitgeber noch mit ehemaligen Kollegen zusammen?
Ja, ein paar sind auch dahin gewechselt.
Kann man auf Twitter filtern nur nach Videos, geht das?
Boah, leck mich, ey.
Kann man nach nur Videos filtern, irgendwie?
Alter, es ist schon ein bisschen ärgerlich, dass ich das hochgeladen hab.
Ist ja alles noch von diesem Jahr.
Weil das eine Video Frankfurt bei Nacht war wirklich nice.
Oh, meine dicke Katze.
Hey da, Kat.
Ich scroll da jetzt einfach mal durch und dann suche ich nach Frankfurt.
Okay, so lang ist das, glaube ich, noch nicht her.
Alter, wie lange ich schon Zeug auf Twitter gepostet habe.
Oh, Fressworts, ein nice Fressworts gab es da.
Frankfurt City Night, gute Battlefield Map.
Ich finde, das macht schon ein bisschen was her, die Frankfurter Skyline.
Ja, Commerzbank.
Also hier.
Nee, nicht Commerzbank.
Äh, war doch Commerzbank?
Kann man es immer nicht merken.
Das macht doch was her.
Ich finde, das sieht cool aus.
Gibt es einen bestimmten Grund, warum du US Keyboard Layout benutzt?
Ich benutze kein US Keyboard Layout.
Ich benutze englische Sprache und deutsches Keyboard Layout.
Next Level.
Okay, was können wir den Fiverr Leuten schreiben?
Also ich habe meinen Emote-Auftrag, den wir nicht machen werden,
den Emote-Auftrag habe ich viel zu ausführlich geschrieben.
I'm looking for bla bla bla bla bla.
Okay, also was können wir den Fiverr Leuten schreiben, was programmiert werden soll?
Okay, mach mal so.
Hi, I'm a Twitch Streamer.
Ich schicke dem aber nicht meinen Namen, sonst guckt er nämlich nach.
I'm looking for a web application with backends.
Was verschreiben wir denn jetzt?
I am a Twitch Streamer.
I often miss important chat messages.
Wie kann man das beschreiben, was das macht?
Also jetzt geht man mal nicht mit Englisch auf den Kick.
That logs and highlights chat messages sent to me.
To improve my collaboration with the chat, I'm looking for a tool to monitor any messages directly to...
Oh ja, der Chat kennt sich aus, das finde ich gut.
Das finde ich schon mal viel besser als das, was ich gedacht habe.
To improve my collaboration with the chat, I'm looking for a tool to monitor any messages directly sent to me at username.
I am a Twitch Streamer.
Ich muss dir bloß noch sagen, was ich haben will.
Interaction. Ja, viel besser.
To improve my collaboration with the chat, I'm looking for a tool to monitor any messages directly to...
Oh ja, viel besser.
To monitor, to log and highlight any messages that mention my username.
Okay, front and should, front and be in any...
And back and must be...
Okay, ich glaube man checkt jetzt ungefähr...
Da versteht man ungefähr, was ich haben will, oder?
Wow, the fuck?
Alter, was jetzt?
Alter, warum klingelst du?
Das ist bei der Temperaturanzeigewecker-Ding gewesen. Ich weiß nicht, warum der jetzt um 12 einfach mal anfängt zu klingeln.
Ich weiß es nicht.
So, wir brauchen jetzt noch...
Wir brauchen noch ein Bild vom Frontend, dass der checkt, was ich...
Obbei, ich brauch kein Bild vom Frontend.
Also, das kommt jetzt... Leute, das versteht man doch, oder?
Hi, I'm a Twitch-Team. I often miss important chat messages.
To improve my interaction with the chat, I'm looking for a tool to monitor, log and highlight any messages that mention my username.
Frontend can be written in any JavaScript, HTML framework you want.
But, the backend must be an ASP.NET Core App.
So.
Wo fehlt denn A?
I am...
Ah!
Twitch. Ich glaub, Twitch schreibt man nach Cross.
Wir müssen uns jetzt noch mal überlegen, nicht, dass da irgendwie einer auf die Idee kommt, ein reines Frontend zu basteln.
Na gut, ein reines Frontend geht ja nicht, weil man eine SQL-Datenbank braucht.
Wir schreiben ja hier...
Monitor, log, save.
That mention my username.
Any messages that mention my...
Frontend can be written in any... you want?
Okay, okay, wir machen noch eins.
Das ist jetzt Bonus, Bonus-Punkte.
Ah, nee, das ist dann nicht...
Bonus-Points.
Gibt's noch ein paar Bonus-Punkte, die wir vielleicht gerne hätten?
Wo er sich ein bisschen austoben kann?
Was könnte man noch so einfaches einbauen? Ich mein, was kann mein PP-Gabon...
Ach so, äh, Delete-Button.
Ja.
Wie viel bezahlst du dafür? 477.
Nee, Twitch-E-Mouse ist zu viel, das ist zu hart.
Button to delete.
Buttons to delete a specific message or all messages.
Das ist schon fast Ausbeutung, ey, ich hab...
Ausbeutung wär's, wenn er sich nicht dagegen wehren könnte.
Der hat freiwillig das Angebot reingestellt, dass er für 477 was programmiert.
Und er sagt für 477, I will develop your complex website in ASP.NET MVC.
Und der... Oh, include source code brauchen wir, include source code, richtig.
Okay, ich würd jetzt noch gerne...
Ich bin mir nämlich nicht mehr sicher, ähm, warum ich das...
Was war mein Gedanke dazu, nicht einfach ne Webseite zu machen?
Weil ich mein, man müsste doch eigentlich auch von der Webseite Twitch abfragen können.
Warum hab ich ein Backend gemacht? Weil ich speichern wollte.
Genau, weil ich ne Datenbank haben wollte, was die Nachrichten speichert.
Browser unabhängig.
Ach ja, wisst ihr was, was wir noch reinschreiben sollen?
Dass die Anwendung funktionieren muss ohne Twitch-Login.
Muss funktionieren ohne Login, ohne Twitch-Login.
Wollen wir eben noch reinschreiben, dass er die Twitch IRC-RP verwenden soll?
Ne, das wär zu viel Hilfe, oder?
Das wär zu viel Hilfe.
Das soll er selbst rauskriegen.
Ja, das wär zu viel Hilfe, denk ich auch.
So, I am a Twitch streamer, I often miss important chat messages.
To improve my interaction with the chat, I am looking for a tool to monitor, log and highlight any messages that mention my username.
Frontend can be written any JSL HTML framework you want, but the backend must be ASP.NET Core.
Must be ASP.NET Core application.
Application must work without Twitch-Login.
Bonus points. Frontend should refresh itself when a new message is registered.
Buttons to delete a specific message or all messages.
Also im Prinzip genau das, was ich ja auch eingebaut hab, plus dass mein Button nicht funktioniert.
So Leute, also es waren ja vorher ein paar Leute da, die haben gesagt, sie würden sich auch gerne dran probieren.
Wie gesagt, meine, nennen wir es mal, Referenzimplementierung ist hier.
Die hab ich ja lokal, die funktioniert auch.
Also man braucht ungefähr 200 Zeilen Code für ungefähr, inklusive HTML, JavaScript und C-Sharp-Code.
Achso, was wir noch reinschreiben sollten ist, Chat messages should survive application restart.
Nicht, dass der auf die Idee kommt, das alles in Ram zu schreiben oder so.
Das soll doch schon der SQLite Datenbank oder so drunter hauen, ja.
Chat messages should survive application restart.
So, man versteht's, oder? Habt ihr noch, hättet ihr noch was?
Also ich meine, keine zusätzlichen Punkte. Hättet ihr noch irgendwas, wie man es klarer schreiben kann?
Ich finde, das ist eigentlich relativ klar.
Ich meine, man sieht, ich bin Twitch-Streamer, der Nachrichten verpasst.
Deswegen hätte ich gerne ein Tool, was eben den Chat überwacht, wenn mein Username erwähnt wird, ja.
Der Frontend darf er machen, wie er will, aber das Backend muss eine ASP.NET Core Anwendung sein, ja.
Das Ganze muss funktionieren ohne Login auf Twitch.
Tippfehler in Application.
Könntest du das auch selber schreiben? Hab ich ja schon, hier, da.
Läuft ja schon.
Das haben wir schon vor Wochen selber gemacht. Das sind 200 Zeilen Code oder sowas.
Ich will jetzt wissen, der Witz ist ja, ich will wissen, was die Fiverr-Leute daraus machen, weil ich meine, für vier, ganz ehrlich,
für 4,77 Euro, den Code gibt es nirgendswo, das wäre ja witzlos. Für 4,77 Euro erwarte ich nichts, ehrlich gesagt.
Basic development and bug-fixing, standard create. Ach so, da will mehr für eine Anwendung, okay.
Programs will consist of a single class of, okay, bei dem müssten wir 14 Euro ausgeben, bei dem müssten wir, bei dem müssten wir schon 57 Euro ausgeben.
Ich suche mir mal welche raus, die das machen und dann, dann mach ich einen Auftrag.
Das ist witzig, das bin ich mal gespannt, da bin ich echt mal gespannt, was dabei rauskommt.
I will create your website, okay, was haben wir, was haben wir sonst noch für, I will create your website, den hatten wir gerade schon.
I will develop your complex website in ASP.NET MVC. Drei Tage Delivery, one revision, 4,77.
Okay Leute, Ordner hinzufügen, Progas. Ich hasse, ich hasse diese Lesezeichen von, okay, den speichern wir uns, Progas, 4,77.
Okay, na, wie sucht man hier am besten danach, ASP.NET?
I will develop web applications ASP. Das sind Inderes, sind alles Inderes, oder, vom Namen her?
Zeyed Ashar.
Na, die Usernamen, den Usernamen kann er ja konfigurierbar machen.
Ja, so meinst du das Flo, ja, nein, mein Username erwähne ich nicht.
Okay, reliable, secured, full functional web application, exactly according to requirements, five pages including source code.
Save, Progas.
Der ist zu teuer, das ist ja ein realistischer Preis, das wollen wir natürlich nicht bezahlen.
Den hatten wir schon, oder?
Bei dem kostet er aber 57 Euro.
I will create or modify your ASP.NET Reapplication.
7 Euro ist zu teuer. Zu teuer, mit mehr als 10 Euro bezahlen wir nicht.
I will develop your enterprise websites with ASP.NET Core.
6 pages responsive design including source code, easy.
Ich kann die nach den Bewertungen suchen. Best selling.
I will create a website as per your requirements.
7,70 Euro. Warum sind die alle so billig?
Wie sucht man denn hier? Programming, hier, Programming Websites, Web Programming.
Wir können auch eine Ruby on Rails Anwendung.
19 Euro, zwei Tage Delivery.
Das ist gut, das gefällt mir. Der passt, der passt genau.
Und er sollte auch wissen, was er da macht.
Er hat auch gute Bewertungen, den nehmen wir, den nehmen wir.
20 Euro, geschenkt.
Wie gesagt, für 20 Euro machen die meisten Leute nicht mehr ihre Idee auf.
Was soll man drinnen zu sagen?
Auf der Grill Websites. Wie hatten wir eben den Geekhead hatten wir eben.
I will develop ASP.NET Core on MVC Web Applications. Für 9 Euro. Perfekt.
Will fix your bugs in this package. Develop University Project Assignment and Features.
Achso, da macht er nichts Neues.
Wie mehr ASP gibt es da?
Ich kann hier leider nicht gescheit suchen danach.
Da muss man hier...
SharePoint Support.
Den hatten wir gerade schon.
Oh, das ist ja mal ein ernstzunehmender Preis. Das wollen wir natürlich nicht bezahlen.
I will develop any type of ASP.NET Core Application and API.
Also ich würde sagen, ich überlege mal, 100 Euro gebe ich aus dafür.
Das ist mir der Spaß wert.
Also 100 Euro gebe ich aus. Ich werde es so machen, ich suche mir ein paar Leute raus, die halt ultra billig sind.
Und dann zwei, die ein bisschen teurer sind.
Und dann vergleichen wir das Ganze mal und gucken, was da rauskommt.
Diese Sorte Fiverr Videos sind auch auf YouTube vorangesagt gerade. Ich glaube das kommt gut an.
Den hatten wir gerade schon.
Bisschen schwierig was zu finden.
Den hatten wir auch schon. Das war der für 477. Den probiere ich aus.
Da könnt ihr euch drauf verlassen. Den probiere ich auf.
Den probiere ich aus. Für 477.
I will develop so complex works of ASP.NET One Revision 477.
Kein Source Code.
Na ja, wenn ich das laufen lassen soll bei mir, muss es ja Source Code geben. Wie soll ich das laufen lassen, richtig?
Führt dann nicht irgendeinen mir unbekannten Inderkram aus.
Okay, continue.
Kann man vielleicht noch Source Code auswählen?
Bonus, Bonus Source Code?
Das schreibe ich ihm dabei, dass ich Source Code haben will. Da lege ich auch nochmal 5 Euro drauf.
Gönner heute, oder? Voller Gönner. Gibt es schon mal 9,50 Euro für die Anwendung.
Und den probieren wir auch aus. Oder war das der, wo man Basic nehmen muss, wo man Standard nehmen muss?
Ja.
I will design any kind of database SQL ASP.NET Web App.
My expert...
Der arbeitet 3 Tage für 9,53 Euro?
Okay, also. Moment, das müssen wir bei dem anderen haben. Das haben wir bei dem anderen gar nicht geguckt. Was hat er noch reingeschrieben?
Dear customer, I am a senior software engineer and have more than 3 years of programming. Blablabla.
C-Sharpmachter, View, Bootstrap, jQuery.
Okay, da steht leider nichts zu Source Code dabei.
Unlimited Revisions.
Also ich brauche auf jeden Fall den Source Code. Ohne Source Code ist das langweilig.
So viele Leute... Ich muss erstmal Leute raussuchen, die potentiell dafür in Frage kommen.
Ich will auf jeden Fall den Source Code. Ohne Source Code ist das langweilig. Ansonsten müssen wir jetzt die kompilen oder so.
I will develop Web App Web API in ASP.NET Core.
Included Source Code. Das ist er. Das Steff019.
.NET Core Anwendung mit Angular. Design.
Include Source Code.
ASP. Genau das wollen wir haben. Genau das wollen wir haben.
I will work on the backend side. Genau das wollen wir haben.
Genau den wollen wir haben. Der wird beauftragt.
I will fix your HTML.
Ja, mit 10 Tagen ist auch... Also für den Preis kann man wirklich nicht erwarten, dass es schneller geht oder so.
I will do...
ASP.NET MVC Bootstrap. Den hatten wir eben schon.
I will design book covers. Warum genau ist er in Programming drinnen?
I will create the application with simple pages. Den hatten wir schon.
Den hatten wir auch schon eben, glaube ich.
Including Source Code.
I will fix bugs and develop small, complete static website.
Wo ist... Hä?
Complete static website, allerdings hat es 3-5 dynamic pages.
Was auch immer.
Alles zu teuer. Alles zu teuer. Die wollen ja noch richtig Geld dafür haben.
Okay. Ich glaube wir haben genug. Die werde ich mal alle anhauen und ihnen das hier schicken.
I'm a Twitch streamer. Okay.
Da bin ich echt gespannt, was rauskommt. Da bin ich echt gespannt.
Können euch gar nicht vorstellen. Da bin ich wirklich...
Da bin ich wirklich sehr gespannt drauf.
Macht es Sinn, die PS4 in der Fritzbox als DMZ einzudragen? Nö.
Ich würde immer nur die Ports weiterleiten, die ich brauche.
Und normalerweise brauchst du es, sei denn du willst Scott irgendwelche Sachen hosten oder so. Gar keine Ports weiterleiten.
Welchen Clipboard Manager du für Linux verwendest?
Irgendwas Selbstgestricktes.
Irgendein Rofi Plugin, glaube ich. Weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Clipster, Clipster, Rofi, irgendwie sowas.
Okay, ich bin begeistert. Fiverr.
Was kann man da sonst noch so kaufen auf Fiverr eigentlich, wenn man was programmiert haben will?
Schauen wir mal Desktop, Desktop Applications.
Da weiß ich nicht mehr, was das überhaupt ist.
Three Days Delivery.
Cryptocurrency Trading Bot.
Was man nicht alles auf Fiverr kauft.
Linux Programming für 477.
Very Simple C++.
Das müsste man auch mal ausprobieren.
C++ Anwendung für 477.
Was ist Very Simple?
Anstatt Hello World, Hello Fiverr.
Cute Entwicklung.
Ja, auch 477.
Die ganzen Interprogrammer hier.
Lustig.
Ja, also das machen wir jetzt nicht im Stream, weil ich will hier keine Kreditkarten und Gedulds eingeben.
Wenn ich das hier order.
Für 477 schmeißt niemand sein Rechner an, dann sollen sie nicht 477 reinschreiben.
Wenn die da 477 stehen haben, dann zwingt sie ja keiner, die Sachen für 477 da reinzuschreiben.
Ich finde es auch unrealistisch. Ich würde auch für 477 keinen Finger krumm machen.
Aber wenn man sich auf einer Seite anmeldet, denn ein Angebot erstellt für 477, dann würde ich auch erwarten, dass man für 477 was macht.
Das ist ein sehr guter Tipp.
Ich brauche das Trinker.
Das mache ich jetzt aber offstream, weil ich will meine Kreditkarten und PayPal Zeug hier nicht eingeben.
Ja.
Perfekt.
I will help in Java Programming.
Bloß nicht.
Alter, warum haben wir 52 Zuschauer?
Nice.
Wahrscheinlich kommen viele von YouTube, Leute.
Kommen viele von YouTube? Wie sieht es aus?
Oder habt ihr es über Twitch gefunden?
Nach Kobold programmieren, euer.
Was hat das mit Kobold zu tun?
Show me your style so far cool instead of Kobold.
Nicht Kobold, Kobold.
Kobold-Programmer.
Man kann auch gar nicht direkt search instead for Kobold.
Kobold.
Your Kobold mainframe environment. Boah krass.
IBM haust Geschichten in Kobold.
Kobold-Programming 477.
Twitch Prime.
Von Twitch Prime auf richtiges Abo gewechselt.
Pock.
Erst mal gucken, was ich nicht für Leute vergessen habe, die gesubbt haben.
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Kobold.
Ich frage mich, warum wir da überhaupt noch auf der Arbeit ein eigenes Team für Datenbacken und ein eigenes Team für Mainframe haben.
Weil man sich das doch einfach für 477 bei Fiverr kaufen kann.
Soll ich mal vorschlagen?
Ich schlage das mal vor als huge Einsparpotenzial.
Einfach alle DBAs und alle Mainframe Leute entlassen und Fiverr einkaufen.
Und ich kriege den Bonus, den man einspart.
Max wird durch Fiverr ersetzt, genau.
Spielt es keinen Warteschlangensimulator? Nee.
Wenn ich mit WoW Classic angefangen hätte, dann Max wohl als erstes entlassen.
Das ist unbefristet.
Einfach geht das nicht.
Wenn ich jetzt WoW anfangen würde, dann würde ich keine Videos mal machen und keine Streams mehr.
Deswegen habe ich nicht mit WoW angefangen.
Also ich bin begeistert. Die Fiverr-Geschichte wird echt lustig, Leute.
Das habe ich so im Gefühl.
Und außerdem, wenn ich entlassen werde, ist kein Ding.
Dann gehe ich einfach auf Fiverr und melde mich an für 4,76 Euro.
Und unterbiete alle.
Wahrscheinlich ist 4,77 Euro das Niedrigste, was man anbieten kann, oder?
Naja, wie dem auch sei, genug Fiverr.
Wollen wir noch was gucken?
Eigentlich ist jetzt 12.30 Uhr, ich zeige euch mal was Futter.
Oder mal anfangen, Mittagessen zu machen.
Fiverr-Auftrag mache ich nachher.
Ach ja, übrigens Leute, für alle, die auf YouTube zugeschaltet haben,
es ist schön, dass ihr den Weg auch hier auf Twitch gefunden habt.
Also als Info für alle, die neu sind hier auf Twitch,
falls ihr einen Amazon Prime-Account habt,
könnt ihr den kostenlos mit eurem Twitch-Account verbinden.
Das Ganze gibt dann Twitch Prime.
Dafür bekommt ihr eben monatkostenloses Twitch Prime-Loot.
Und das Beste ist, ihr könnt einen Streamer eurer Wahl
kostenlos mit einem Tier-One-Sub unterstützen.
Das könnt ihr einmal im Monat machen.
Kostet euch nichts. Normalerweise würde es 5 Euro kosten.
Und ihr bekommt alle Vorteile, die das mit sich bringt.
Also sprich, ihr bekommt eine Sub-Batch, ihr bekommt Emotes.
Und wir haben eh die nicesten Emotes hier im Channel.
Ich habe noch 10 frei, ich muss noch mehr Emotes.
Aber die Emotes, die wir jetzt haben, sind natürlich Big-Brain-Emotes.
Und außerdem sinkt der Durchschnittsping
und es steigt der Durchschnitts-IQ jedes Zuschauers mit jedem Sub.
Also das heißt, wenn ihr any Primers am Start sind,
dann wisst ihr ja, was man damit machen kann jetzt.
So, genug Sell-Out.
Schlank, schattig, Twitch Prime. Dankeschön.
Das klappt jedes Mal.
Moin.
Ping-Sell-Out kannst du lassen.
Ein bisschen Cringe ist nicht schlecht.
Und Cringe ist für mehr Sell-Out immer von Vorteil.
Eco-Chanics. Dankeschön.
Five-Hand-Subscriber.
Any Gifters.
Wie war das?
Wie war das? Never Subbed?
Never Donated?
Free Entertainment?
Ich krieg das gerade nicht zusammen. Warte mal, wie ging das?
Ja.
Never Subbed, Never Donated,
Ad-Blog, OnStone, Laptop, Neighbors, Wi-Fi,
Free Entertainment.
So, jetzt können wir ja mal mein Chat,
mein, das
Pepega-Board angucken.
Ob ich irgendwas übersehen hab
an Chat-Nachrichten.
Ja,
ja,
ja.
Ja,
Man muss ja einen Grund haben, warum es so viele für 4,77 Euro gibt.
Das würde ich nicht unbedingt auf Fiverr beauftragen, ich weiß nicht.
47 Euro! Huge!
Cisco Leute! Ah, das wollten wir mal gucken, genau.
Gibt es Cisco Experten auf Fiverr?
I will do configuration of VPN, Switch, Cisco Router and Microtech.
Ja, gibt es auch Cisco Experten auf Fiverr.
Auch für 4,77.
Ach, haha, der macht für dich Packet Tracer, Cisco Packet Tracer Aufgaben, löst er für dich.
Ist ja witzig, was da nicht alles gibt.
5 Euro sind 400 Indische Rupees.
Ah ja, okay.
Ist sonst glaub ich nix mehr dabei.
Wo hast du eigentlich dein Microtech Zeug gekauft?
Bei Amazon?
Nee?
Bei...
Hatte so ganz, hatte eigentlich einen super einprägsamen...
Ah, bei denen hier, genau.
Bei denen hier hab ich viel bestellt.
Weil die über, ich hab die über Geizhals gesucht und die waren relativ günstig.
OMG.
Omg.
Omg.de
Ich glaub hier hab ich viel gekauft, aber
Leute, ich kann euch schon empfehlen, geht über Geizhals.
Geht über Geizhals, weil die Angebote, wenn du über den Geizhals-Link in Online-Shops rein gehst,
dann sind die oftmals billiger, als wenn du direkt über Google und sonst was über den Shop gehst.
Omegalol.de, tatsächlich, die Seite gibt's ja wirklich.
Warum gibt es die Seite Omegalol.de?
xKuchen1, moin.
Also, ich kann dir nur empfehlen, Buchhalter, Access Point bringt wirklich was.
Also, zum Beispiel, diese Ubiquiti Access Points, auch schon die kleinen,
die sind noch ein Vielfaches besser als das meiste WLAN-Zeug, was in so einem Router drin ist.
Wie gesagt, ich hab ja den da.
Ich hab den da.
Allerdings, die haben mittlerweile neue.
Die haben mittlerweile neue, ich würd die jetzt nicht mal einfach so kaufen.
Die haben eine neue Serie rausgebracht, die auch ziemlich gut sein soll,
und ein bisschen billiger ist.
Ja, aber das ist wirklich ein Top-Access-Point.
Leider braucht man entweder, man kann den administrieren entweder über eine App
auf einem Smartphone oder auf einem Tablet,
oder man muss sich einen UniFi-Controller installieren auf einem Raspberry oder irgendwo anders.
Das ist das einzig Dumme an den Dingern, so ein bisschen,
dass die kein eigenständiges Web-Interface haben,
im Gegensatz zu den Mikrotik-Dingern.
Hoste deinen Minecraft-Server auf einem UniFi-AP.
Nee, da läuft schon ein Staubsauger.
Verwendest du noch dein Blue Yeti-Microphone?
Äh, wenn ja, hast du ein Auto-Interface.
Ja, hab ich.
Also das Blue Yeti steht hier neben bei mir, verwende ich aber selten.
Ich verwende eigentlich hauptsächlich nur das Mikrofon am MMX300, am Headset,
weil es halt einfach ist, das habe ich eh schon auf.
Da wird einfach das Mikro runtergeklappt und aufgenommen.
Dann Audio-Interface habe ich auch, ja,
einfach aus dem Grund, ich habe so viele Sachen zum Anschließen mittlerweile.
Das Mikro, die Konsolen, die zwei PCs zusammen.
Da habe ich noch ein kleines Mischpult dran.
Als Audio-Interface habe ich
das da, aber da gibt es bestimmt mittlerweile schon was Neues.
Das Audio-Interface habe ich schon seit ein paar Jahren.
Das da habe ich als Audio-Interface.
Das ist richtig gut.
Hat massig viele Eingänge.
Ist gut.
Aber gibt mittlerweile bestimmt günstigeres und besseres.
Wie gesagt, das habe ich schon seit, keine Ahnung, acht Jahren oder so.
Ja, WLANs können die meisten, Buchhalter,
WLANs können die meisten Konsumer-Dinger nicht.
Da fährst du mit so einem Ubiquiti-Ding schon nicht verkehrt.
Allerdings muss natürlich dein Router auch WLANs können.
Also es reicht nicht, es reicht nicht wirklich,
wenn dein Exist-Point WLANs kann.
TP-Link.
Ja, ich weiß, ich habe auch einen ganz billigen TP-Link Exist-Point.
Also den, den ich davor hatte, den ganz billigen, der kann auch WLANs.
Und das war so ein 20-Euro-Ding vor zehn Jahren.
Billiges Grab-Ding kann auch WLANs.
Die TP-Link-Dinger überraschen mich eh immer wieder.
Die haben zwar meistens ein super hässliches, kompliziertes Webfronten,
aber Features ist gar nicht so schlecht.
So ein billiges Ding.
Kennst du von MikroTik die PCI Express DSL?
Muss ich gar nicht, dass die sowas haben.
Die haben sowas?
Nee, oder? Wie heißt denn das?
Genau, eigenes IoT-Netz würde ich auf jeden Fall machen.
Also generell eigenes Netz für China-Sachen.
Also ich habe es ja bei mir eh so, ich habe zwei unterschiedliche WLANs.
Also eigentlich habe ich sogar drei WLANs.
Eins für alle Tablets und Smartphones, eins für China-Kram,
was weder rein und raus darf irgendwo hin und für Testkram.
So, wir sind jetzt 2 Stunden und 40, ich würde sagen wir sind wach, oder?
Sind wir wach?
Nee.
Na klar.
Also anscheinend sind wir doch nicht wach.
Aber mal eine Frage zum P-Hole.
Das Ding hat echt einen unglücklichen Namen, muss ich sagen.
Pie-Hole.
Auf diversen Seiten wollen sie, dass man Adblock ausschalten.
Wie sieht das aus, wenn man Pie-Hole hat?
Kommt auf die Webseite an.
Allerdings ist Pie-Hole eh nicht mehr das, was ich verwenden würde.
Es gibt leider keine ordentliche Alternative dazu.
Außer einen Adblocker im Browser, weil Seiten wie YouTube zum Beispiel
liefern mittlerweile die Werbung vom gleichen Server aus, wie die Videos.
Das heißt, du kannst mit Pie-Hole nichts mehr blocken.
Twitch macht es ähnlich.
Das heißt, es hilft nur noch einen Adblocker im Browser,
wo die große Kacke daran ist, dass der Adblocker im Browser
halt auf dem Desktop gut funktioniert, auf Android teilweise auch.
Allerdings auf iOS gibt es sowas nicht.
Doch, es gibt Adblocker für iOS, die funktionieren allerdings nicht
in der YouTube- oder Twitch-App.
Das ist ein bisschen kacke.
Willst du uns mal deine QoS-Settings zeigen?
Ich kann meinen Router hier nicht aufmachen.
Da sieht man zu viel Zeug drin.
Was benutzt du als Firewall?
Ich benutze die eingebauten IP-Filter-Sachen in meinem Mikrotik-Router.
Unter der Haube ist dann die Lux drunter mit IP-Tables,
unter den ganzen Mikrotik-Dingern.
PS4, ja, ist ja ähnlich wie ein Android-Gerät oder ein iOS.
Das ist halt geschlossen, die Plattform.
Du kannst keinen Adblocker darauf installieren.
Und es kommt auf die Webseite an, ob die meckern oder nicht.
Ich würde mal sagen, dass die meisten Webseiten
mit einem DNS-Blocker nicht meckern,
sondern einfach nicht richtig funktionieren,
wenn sie nämlich quasi Werbung und Content
von der gleichen Domain laden.
Twitch bekommst du gar nicht mehr geplockt,
weil es im Stream eingebunden ist.
Doch.
Aber ich will jetzt hier keine Werbung für Twitch-Adblocker machen.
Das wäre irgendwie kontraproduktiv für mich selbst.
Selbst Linus Tech-Tipps kann ich zaubern.
PyHall funktioniert nicht auf Twitch und YouTube.
PyHall funktioniert auf keinen Seiten,
die Content und Werbung von der gleichen Domain ausliefern.
Wie soll das funktionieren?
PyHall sorgt dafür, dass manche Domains
nicht aufgelöst werden können.
Wenn du jetzt ein Domain hast,
wo Content und Werbung von ausgeliefert wird,
geht halt der Content nicht.
Und dann ist die Frage, warum gehst du überhaupt auf die Seite?
Das stimmt für Android.
Deswegen sage ich ja, für iOS ist das das Problem.
Für Android ist kein Ding.
Für Android hast du Custom-Apps für YouTube.
Welchen Adblocker origin, äh, uBlock Origin beste?
Gibt's für Firefox, für Chrome, wahrscheinlich sogar für Edge.
Sogar für Firefox auf Android.
Mit Prime hast du eh keine Werbung.
Das stimmt nicht.
Prime kriegt ganz normal Werbung, wie jede andere auch mittlerweile.
Das haben die schon vor einem halben Jahr abgeschafft,
dass Prime keine Werbung mehr schaut.
Äh, dass Prime Werbung abschaltet, ist nicht mehr so.
Mit Prime hast du im ganzen Handy, das stimmt.
Aber PyHall und Twitch geht nicht.
Guck zu hier.
Wenn ihr mir das nicht glaubt.
Die liefern von TwitchTV Content und Werbung aus.
Keine Chance.
Und selbst Salinos kann nichts dagegen tun.
Wo ist das Video?
Ah.
Jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob es da irgendwas Neues gibt,
was wir noch nicht wussten.
Also wie gesagt, ich wüsste nicht, wie PyHall funktionieren soll
mit Twitch und YouTube aktuell.
YouTube weiß ich nicht, Twitch auf jeden Fall nicht.
Das ist immer noch ein ganz normaler DNS-Blocker.
Das kann die Sachen logischerweise nicht filtern,
wenn Content und Werbung von der gleichen Domain kommen.
Wahrscheinlich hat er das sogar überlebt.
Aber er ist relativ robust.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber Adblocker im Browser funktionieren an Stellen,
wo DNS-Adblocker nicht funktionieren können.
Ein Adblocker kann Twitch und YouTube Werbung blocken.
Ein DNS-Blocker kann das nicht.
Wenn ihr mir das nicht glaubt, wollen wir das im nächsten Stream probieren.
Wir probieren das im nächsten Stream aus.
Im nächsten Stream setze ich einen PyHall auf
und mache irgendwie Weiterleitungen.
Oder wir gucken uns dann an, ob Twitch-Werbung blockt wird.
Ich sage euch, es wird nicht blockt.
Max, dist den DNS-Blocker.
Das klingt ziemlich aufwendig.
Du startest den Image auf einer SD-Card und startest den Raspberry.
Das war's.
Wir müssen das übrigens noch nicht mehr auf dem Raspberry machen.
Wir können das einfach bei mir auf dem Server im Docker-Container starten.
Oder hier, ich kann es in der VM machen.
Ein paar PyHalls installieren, das war kein Problem.
Können wir machen. Machen wir jetzt.
Machen wir jetzt. Easy. Machen wir nicht im nächsten Stream. Machen wir jetzt.
Hab ich überhaupt noch genug Festplattenplatz hier frei?
Oh.
Wir haben keinen Platz mehr.
Warum ist die VM so voll?
Monkeys.
Warum ist die VM so voll? Was habe ich da alles drauf?
Wir gucken mal.
Was da so viel Speicher verbraucht?
3-4 GB bräuchte schon Platz.
Da haben wir was zu installieren.
Warum ist das so langsam?
Ah fuck, das ist so langsam, weil ich die VM nicht auf der SSD, sondern auf der Festplattlinie habe.
Wahr ist massig voll. Cache.
Können wir schon mal alles löschen. Brauchen wir nicht mehr.
Snap ist.NET.
Das ist okay. Das darf drauf bleiben.
Cache. Cache kann schon mal alles weg.
Package.
Pack cache. Pack cache.
Pack, Alter. Pack cache.
Minus RK1.
Okay, wir haben wieder Speicherplatz. Easy.
Okay.
Also.
Starten wir mit Ubuntu 18.04.
Und, äh, ne Moment. PyHall.
Wie ging das? Brauchen wir da, brauchen wir da Debian für?
Brauchen wir dann?
Ich zeige euch jetzt, dass es nicht funktioniert.
So, PyHall. Das ist das, was die installieren. Install.
Brauchen wir dann Debian oder geht das auch unter Ubuntu?
Wir machen es ja nicht auf dem Raspberry. Ich mache es hier im Container, aber mir lokal.
Äh, PyHall.
Geht auch unter Ubuntu. Sehr schön, wenn das unter Ubuntu geht. Da bin ich zufrieden.
Hauptsache wichtig ist, dass die Sachen unter Ubuntu funktionieren.
Unter Ubuntu kann man sich darüber streiten, aber Ubuntu ist wichtig.
Wie kannst du so schön zwischen PC und VM switchen?
Steuerung, Alt, äh, äh, äh, Steuerung, Windows, File-Taste.
Ich habe drei Desktops. Da ist der Browser auf, da ist die VM auf, da ist nichts auf.
Ubuntu, nicht Ubuntu. Jetzt wird es jetzt immer noch komplizierter.
Ubuntu, Ubuntu, äh, Ubuntu, Ubuntu, Ubuntu, was auch immer.
So, PyHall installieren.
Was muss ich jetzt noch machen?
Installieren wir das mal. Dann schauen wir mal.
Installer will transform your device into a network wide ad blocker. Okay.
It's free, okay. It's a server, it needs static IP address. Okay.
Select upstream DNS, äh, Google, okay.
Manual lists, alles, bam. IPv6 haben wir gar nicht an, aber auch 104933.
Oh, ich habe keine globale IP auf dem Container, aber es ist egal. Wir machen es von Linux aus.
Yes. IP-Konflikt. Ach so.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, äh, okay.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir erstmal uns Twitch an und schauen, dass es nicht, ach so.
Das ist Firefox. Okay. Chrome, machen Chrome auf, machen Twitch auf.
Da werden wir jetzt Werbung kriegen. Es sei denn, ich habe ja auch einen Ad Blocker drinne.
New Incognito-Window, da gibt es nämlich keinen Ad Blocker. Twitch.
So, wir machen jetzt irgendwas auf. Ja, Method Starcraft, da gibt es Werbung.
Oder auch nicht. Ja gut, weil die gerade keine Werbung senden.
Wo gibt es denn Werbung? Ich brauche mal einen Channel, wo es Werbung gibt.
YouTube. YouTube gibt es immer Werbung.
Da gibt es Werbung. Werbung.
Okay, guckt euch an. Immer, immer, wenn ich ein Video aufmache.
Also vor allem, wenn ich hier neuen Incognito-Mode aufmache.
Ups, äh, was mache ich denn?
Immer, wenn ich hier neuen Incognito-Modes aufmache und gehe auf YouTube, dann gibt es Werbung.
Okay, und jetzt stelle ich das auf mein Pie Hall ein. Was haben wir für eine IP da, den hier?
Login Password ist, ach du Scheiße, das kann schon keiner merken.
Und das da ist das Admin Interface, okay.
Ja, Complete Admin Interface. Zack, da ist es.
Oh, Admin Password ist das da. Login Password, bam, save.
Okay, jetzt stelle ich mal mein DNS. Ach so, das ist natürlich doof.
Ich will mein DNS hier eigentlich gar nicht ändern.
Rode PowerShell kann SSH. Ja, mittlerweile, mittlerweile kann es das.
Ähm, eigentlich habe ich gar keinen Bock, mein DNS in meiner VM zu ändern, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Wie mache ich das jetzt am besten?
Weil ich habe das alles ganz gut konfiguriert.
DNS im Browser ändern geht nicht, oder? Kann man mittlerweile DNS im Browser ändern? Eher nicht.
Und das jetzt am besten?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich mein Netzwerkzeug hier eingerichtet habe.
Wahrscheinlich Standard DHCP Zeug. Resolve Conf.
Okay, wir tragen jetzt einfach mal temporär das Ding hier ein.
Wir tragen jetzt einfach mal temporär das Ding hier ein.
Und dann gucken wir mal, ob es funktioniert.
Okay, der nimmt den richtigen DNS Server.
Okay, jetzt probieren wir es aus.
Jetzt sollte ja eigentlich keine Werbung mehr auf YouTube kommen, weil wir jetzt das Pieholding verwenden.
Es ist, es ist enabled.
Es sind auch zwei Clients registriert, die das angeblich verwenden.
Muss man das jetzt irgendwie einschalten? Nee, oder?
Das war's. Man muss da nichts machen sonst.
Wir können unsere, wir können unsere Listen updaten noch.
Wie updatet man die, die, die Spamfilter?
Wo ist das nochmal gewesen? Da?
Update. Das war auch das neueste haben, ja?
Success. Okay, wir haben das neueste.
Okay, also, machen wir, machen wir ein Incognito Tab auf und gehen auf YouTube.
Wahrscheinlich ist das jetzt der Vorführeffekt, es gibt keine Werbung oder so.
Es gibt keine Werbung.
Glaub ich aber erst, wenn ich's sehe.
Da ist Werbung, guck.
Trotz, trotz Piehold.
Piehold funktioniert nicht mehr für YouTube und Twitch.
Der Piehold ist nur lokal hier erreichbar.
Was ist das für eine Werbung? Keine Ahnung, Edeka oder so?
Also das funktioniert nicht mehr.
Check mal Piehold Logs.
Google.
Google Denkbombs wird geblockt. Google Video.com wird geblockt.
DoubleClick wird geblockt.
Kann man hier suchen? YouTube.
Ja, und das ist das Problem, wenn die Ads ausliefern.
Wenn die Ads, ich sage ja, Grün wird nicht geblockt.
So, und wenn die jetzt von YouTube.com Content oder halt von,
ich weiß nicht von wo die das ausliefern, CDN oder irgendwie Videos oder so.
Wenn die Content und Werbung von den gleichen Domains ausliefern, machst du halt nichts.
Geht nicht mehr. Funktioniert nicht.
Twitch funktioniert auch nicht mehr.
Müßt gebastet hier wieder.
Jetzt machen wir die Container aus.
Wieso macht das eigentlich nicht jeder schon lang? Die Lösung war doch offensiv, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es nicht. Verstehe ich auch nicht.
Delete. Pyhol. Bam.
Also funktioniert nicht. Ich habe das, das ist ja auch der Grund, warum ich es bei mir abgeschafft habe.
Diese ganze Pyhol-Geschichte.
Weil erstens, weil es Probleme gemacht hat, bei manchen Seiten das zu laden.
Happy Bird. Und weil es bei Twitch und YouTube nicht mehr funktioniert.
Ist doch nur da umsetzbar, wo die Seitenbetreiber selbst die Ads ausliefern.
Richtig. Deswegen funktioniert es ja auch an vielen Stellen noch, wenn es über irgendwelche Ad, Networks oder sonst was kommt.
Dann funktioniert es natürlich nicht.
Allerdings bei Streaming-Werbung kommt es halt mittlerweile von Twitch oder von YouTube.
Ja, es bringt was, klar.
Aber die YouTube-App wird dadurch nicht werbefrei und die Twitch-App wird dadurch auch nicht werbefrei.
Die normalen Apps, wie gesagt, es funktioniert bei allen, wo die Werbung geladen wird.
Nicht von der Domain, wo der Content kommt.
Das ist bei fast allem der Fall.
Aber bei den wichtigsten Sachen für mich, Twitch und YouTube, ist es nicht der Fall.
Deswegen funktioniert dort Pyhol nicht.
Einfach YouTube und Twitch über Chromecast schauen, da hast du nie Werbung.
Das ist eigentlich keine schlechte Idee.
Kann man über Chromecast auch YouTube browsen oder nur spezielle Videos angucken.
Ich hab das noch nie ausprobiert.
YouTube Premium, das ist ein Grund, warum ich auf Android auch eine Custom YouTube-App verwende.
Weil auf iOS geht mir das so oft in den Sack.
Jedes Mal, wenn du die YouTube-App aufmachst, fragt dich das Ding, ob du Premium haben willst.
Oder ob du YouTube Kids haben willst.
Oder ob du YouTube was auch immer haben willst.
Und dann sagen sie, ja, wenn du das hast, dann darfst du auch im Hintergrund Sachen abspielen.
Dann sag ich mir, leck mich am Arsch.
So eine Basisfunktionalität will ich da nichts für bezahlen.
Deswegen mache ich YouTube auf iOS immer über Opera auf.
Nicht eingeloggt, weil Opera erlaubt im Hintergrund Sachen abzuspielen.
Und andere Android-Browser irgendwie nicht.
Bist du in einer Custom YouTube-App mit Max FPS angemeldet? Nö.
Welche Software nutzt du zum Betreiben deiner VM auf Windows 10, vor allem bei Workstation?
Alles vor allem bei Workstation.
Ich finde es ja auch ein bisschen affig, dass sie die Twitch-App so gebaut haben.
Nicht die Twitch-App, dass sie Twitch Prime so umgebaut haben, dass du wieder Werbung hast.
Opera GX, das war der Gaming-Browser.
Nee, Hyper-V ist nicht beste.
Hyper-V ist für Desktop-Virtualisierung garantiert nicht beste.
Ich habe mir vorhin mal gekauft.
Die haben an Weihnachten immer ganz gute Angebote.
Normalerweise kostet es glaube ich 140 Euro oder so.
Ja, die haben es ein bisschen unbenannt.
Früher war Player kostenlos in Workstation.
An Weihnachten haben die meistens ganz gute Aktionen.
Da gibt es das teilweise eben für 40 Euro oder sowas.
Gucken wir mal, was es denn auf Amazon kostet.
Was zum Teufel soll das sein?
Das sieht nach übelstem Crap aus.
Ah, Windows XP.
Lul, was ist das?
Okay, nichts was ich verwenden würde.
Gibt es nicht zu kaufen.
Der Fenstertitel ist Virtual Box, ernsthaft?
Die verkaufen einfach Virtual Box.
Kacknoobs.
Ah, keine Ahnung Leute.
Jetzt haben wir sogar noch was Sinnvolles gemacht.
Ich werde mir jetzt bei Fiver die Leute raussuchen und anschreiben.
Moment, wo habe ich die Datei überhaupt gespeichert?
Die Datei habe ich ein bisschen am falschen Ort.
Kann man hier irgendwie... Explorer?
Wie startet man hier was?
Reveal.
Da hatte ich überhaupt nichts dran zu suchen.
Ich will das nicht demnächst auf Gitter pushen.
Okay, dann schicke ich den Leuten auf Fiver jetzt mal das Zeug.
Und dann gucken wir mal, was wir da für tolle Anwendungen kriegen.
Kannst du mir einen Switch empfehlen?
Mit 8 bis 10 Ports.
Wenn du nichts Spezielles brauchst, hol den billigsten bei Amazon.
Den billigsten unmanaged Switch auf Amazon.
Hol dir irgendeinen TP-Link oder sonst was.
Wenn du wirklich nichts damit Spezielles machen willst, außer einfach nur Geräte anschließen.
Hol den billigsten von Amazon, den du findest, mit genug Ports.
Dann soll ich nichts falsch machen.
Wenn du ein bisschen mehr machen willst, würde ich mir einen Mikrotik-Switch holen.
Die sind auch relativ günstig und haben richtig gute Features.
Aber wahrscheinlich brauchst du die gar nicht.
Du willst wahrscheinlich einfach nur Geräte anschließen und benutzen.
Dann hol dir den billigsten von Amazon und gut ist.
Einen TP-Link oder sowas.
Oder mal wie Netgear.
Der Switch sollte schon 1 Gigabit haben.
Zeig mir mal einen Switch, der heutzutage nicht Gigabit Ports hat.
Das würde ich gar nicht mehr erwähnen.
Gibt es wirklich noch Switche, die keine...
Ernsthaft?
Ach du Scheiße.
Na gut.
Okay.
Hol dir den billigsten Gigabit-Switch.
Für 14,90 oder so.
Oder hier 12 Port.
Billigste 12 Port-Switch kostet hier 54.
Da muss ich mal gucken, was hat ein Mikrotik so zu bieten in 12 Port-Switches.
Die kleinen haben nämlich alle immer nur 5.
Hier.
8.
Der kostet schon 140.
Und der 24er kostet natürlich ähnlich viel.
Lohnt sich nicht.
Hier ist ein Billing bei Amazon.
Hier.
TP-Link.
Oder Netgear oder sowas.
Ach.
8 Ports, guck mal.
8 Ports Gigabit-Switch, 22 Euro.
Da kann man doch nichts machen.
Ja, Amazon Startseite.
Easy as fuck.
So Leute.
Machen wir Schluss.
Musik ist auch aus.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream oder im nächsten Video.
Bis denn.
CU.
Pepehands, ja.
Das war alles ganz tragisch.
Bis denn.
Tschüss.